and you're telling them that it affects you. So, guess what?
They're going to keep doing it. This is how the internet works.
It It shouldn't be, but that's how it is. Mike, why would you
Mike, what are you doing? Mike, you're insane. Apparently, this
is Anasa. According to Mike, what the I was doing my own. Why
the would I want to spend my time with you when I'm when I'm
filming a show with Dax Flame? You guys are [__]
losers. These guys are the Houthies. They're sitting there with
no technology. They're just lob They're just lobbing like cookie
sugar fueled rockets that's hoping it hits, right? And they hit
something and Idubbbz responds and off of like the clout from
getting air struck by the United States, they just get the fund
raise. Okay. They didn't even have anything that you could get
air strike. They had mud huts. You can't damage them.
It might be time for the ID stuff. It might be time, guys. It
might be time.
coming clean. I don't know if this is your own. I don't know
if you guys have watched the item stuff yet. I have not watched
the whole thing. Okay. And it is good. It is very good. And we've
got the time tonight.
Okay. All right. Here we go. We're firing it up. We're firing
it up. Had something to do with dilating in there. Yeah, there's
something there's something that's funny. Okay. There's something
funny.
But here we're going to go we're going to go to the IDub stuff.
I don't get that one. Two legs. But interesting interesting concept.
Okay. I don't know if this is your own theory or if it's just
like
>> I'm gonna hit play. I'm gonna be right back. I'm just
grabbing more water. Uh it's kind of warm in my place right now.
Give me a second. >> I don't know if this is your own theory
or if it's just like implanted in your brain from all the other
hate videos. There was never a bonus. I never spoke to these
losers about a bonus. If you're going to be a hater ass [__]
take it the full way. By the way, the background is a work in
progress, so you can just tune that out. Today I'm going to be
doing the thing that everyone tells you not to do, and that is
feed the trolls. One of the more important things that I want
to talk about is my relationship with Ana. I love Ana. I love
everything about her. I've only grown to love her more with time,
and a lot of people online don't see it that way. For me, it's
very obvious. I thought more people would be able to catch on.
I am quiet, stoic, not talkative. She is the opposite of that.
She is loud, very talkative, social. People struggle to understand
that dynamic I think especially me being a person who has made
a career of talking online. So yes, Ana will oftent times like
in many relationships be the more talkative one. We've been together
for nearly 10 years and all of it has been online for the public
to see. And there are still people accusing her of cheating,
accusing me of being in an abusive relationship. None of this
is true and there is no evidence for any of this except like
I guess body language experts coming on and being like I don't
being stoic here therefore he's in hell. >> Okay, hang
on. Hang on. Watch the change there. Watch the changes. >> The
I don't know what the that was. I have never gotten >> Look
at Ian in this moment. Oh my god. Like he looks sad. No, he is
disgusted at her. He's >> I wasn't even back. I just didn't
want to leave it. I didn't want to leave it paused forever. I
was like really far away from my desk. Sorry. I was even back
when I paused the first time. I just want to say body language
experts,
PPP and Warski. Body language experts.
dude.
I have no idea.
Okay, you you can't just come on the internet and say this is
like the thing that upsets me most. You can't be targeted by
people like this and feed into them. Yeah, I it is ups. It is
super Why would you ever do this? I It's so baffling to me. Like,
you're actually just a total law cow when you do this, right?
Like, these these guys are just making fun of you. They're not
like trying to dissect your political opinions. They're not trying
to dissect like some anything about you. They're just making
fun of you. There are probably people like if you wanted to go
at Ethan, I'm sure you could go at Ethan and get some sort of
engagement from him, some sort of like response that would make
sense. Dude, Kino Casino, PPP,
they just want to mock you. That's [__] That's all
they want to do. Yeah. He tries to shame PPP. He tries to like
appeal to PPP's better half. Okay. PPP don't have a better half.
PPP is just going to [__] He's just going to go hard
on you all the time, dude. It's It's
This is maybe the most insane video, the the least sensible video
I've ever seen made on the internet. Ever.
Yes. Not only that, the best case scenario,
the best case scenario on the entire internet for them is Idubbbz
responding like this in this exact way.
Should we get Should we get the
Oh my god, Warski. Oh my I I'll I'll figure out a PPP voice.
Okay, I'll figure it out. >> That was I have never gotten
>> Look at Ian in this moment. Oh my god. >> Like
he looks sad. Oh, he is disgusted at her. He's depressed. He's
so
>> He looks disgusted with this. >> He looks so uncomfortable.
He's like, "Should I be here?" He looks so uncomfortable. Look
at this guy's body language. He doesn't want to be there. >> Look
how miserable he looks. >> Do people really not not really
care that Worski was outright adjacent back in the day? I think
PPP might also be Isn't PPP also involved with like right-wing
politics?
I don't know if that matters to anyone. These guys don't really
do like a political show at all. It's a little It's like got
some hints of politics to it, but it's really just a show where
they mock people. They're just laughing at dudes. Okay.
It's uh it's something of a you know, you you could almost call
it a like a snarking show. They might they might be engaging
in a little bit of snarking on people. Okay. Which I I just want
to say if people really hate Snark that much, these guys seem
to be like these guys seem to be like, you know, the kings of
it on the internet right now, if I had to if I had to be honest,
okay, these guys are doing some of the foremost snarking that
exists.
>> Dude, he looks Mr. Dude, he looks like he wants to kill
himself.
>> I mean, I kind of want to kill myself now. Okay, so
they're not a fan of the resting face. All right. Well, I'm not
going to smile all the time, fellas. And and even when I smile,
you guys still like contort it into he's so uncomfortable or
he's smiling through the pain. Yes, Idubbbz, you are literally
explaining why responding to them is pointless.
They're taking your facial expressions, they're taking everything
about you, and they're doing creative writing for people who
hate you and generally just want to laugh at other people on
the internet. That's it. That's all they're engaging in. They're
not doing real criticisms of you. They are just mocking you.
They're just making fun of you. This is something a lot of people
fail to do, right? All you need to do to figure out if you should
engage with somebody or not, is see if they're trying to make
a point. They're trying to make a point on their own, you can
you can engage with that, even if they are like mocking you.
But if they're just mocking with you, mocking you, and they're
not even standing on any sort of business, they're just mocking
you alone. You can't debate people out of that. There's no reason
to
>> Oh, he's so or if you're going to respond, you respond
back in kind talking,
right? That's the only way to respond if you want to do that.
Now, would I do that against like Kino Casino? Probably not.
If I were Idubbbz,
probably not. But you don't engage in like, oh, so they don't
like this. Well, technically, I'm actually very happy with my
wife. Technically, my wife and I are very happy. So, it's weird
that these guys just want to say that we're not happy, but all
evidence indicates that we're very happy together.
What?
Huh? >> He's smiling on his face, >> but inside his
eyes, you can see his >> For some reason, well, not for
some reason. For the reason of
people's view on Only Fans.
Ida's problem is that he pulled the Ethan is not very mentally
well thing. Uh, Ethan is not very mentally well. That's just
an observation any normal human being can make. Ethan is very
much not doing well. Ethan is mentally ill. Yeah, that's every
single person. That doesn't mean you can't engage with the things
Ethan says, by the way. But Ethan is not doing well,
right? And them just not liking Ana. They want to push forward
a narrative that she is actively and continually cheating on
me. And if you listen to freaks like this guy I'm about to show,
it makes sense why. They are obsessed. Ana wants to have into
having with Ana. I think he wants to bang Ana. Ana was horny.
Dude, how do you not feel so stupid just looking at the goofy
backgrounds and outfits that PPP and Warski have? How do you
not feel stupid responding to this like tangibly? Responding
to this as if it's serious
Like you are actually applying clown makeup while doing this
video >> and wanted to have sex with >> clown clown
makeup to your soul.
this. Well, Ana herself to it. >> Do you think that makes
her wet, >> buddy? Cloud. >> That's what I'm saying.
>> What we're describing here is two grown men who are
fantasizing about a stranger and his wife and what they do in
the bedroom or don't do in the bedroom. That is creepy weirdo.
And here we have Idubbbz with the bull, folks. There's Idubbbz
with the bull. >> Um Um It's really just these these guys
these [__] weirdos implied that my wife [__]
a dog. These weirdos implied that my wife a dog and that's really
inappropriate. Okay, that's so inappropriate. He's using
terms to describe a picture of me and my dog and what are we
doing? So many people will tell Ana and I just like don't feed
into the hate. And it's like, okay, we're gonna post some normal
stuff. Ana posts just me with a picture of my dog. And this is
the type of commentary we get about it. >> Dubs with the
bull. Gorgeous Gabe Plowder in the back room of the salon with
all of the male stylists.
If you're curious about the hairdresser these guys are talking
about, I will point you to my disgraced boxing coach, Michael
Briggs. For some reason, this stupid
loser and his dumb as rocks wife decided to go on the Okay, so
this isn't the only thing we get, by the way. We uh we also get
him reacting. He goes on his Twitch stream. He actually reacts
to this video from his boxing coach like on the fly.
>> So, there'll be that as well. Okay. >> Rean Ruben
donated $3 notice is bull. What's this? You >> all right?
Okay. Thank you for the fil their guts. They were getting paid
like $5,000 to go go on this podcast. >> I'm going to be
sending you guys $5,000
for the bonus that you never got. >> I think they were
maybe afraid that they wouldn't get the money if they didn't
thoroughly trash us. So, them maybe thinking that they weren't
trashing us hard enough. Michael Briggs decided to invoke the
name of one of his presumably friends and say that Ana was like
thirsting after him. >> She was >> waiting the fat
guy do sound gay as though do they
dude they're just goofy. They're just like they're just totally
performing. It's like not they're not engaging with reality at
all. I feel like if you respond to them you're like you're totally
like every time. I feel like they could they could be doing actual
gay fanfic and it's still impossible to engage with them and
make them look like bad unless you're like on the same pl like
a level playing field. I feel >> had a big crush on one
of the guys that would come in and spar with them cuz anytime
they would spar she would just be super into it and watch every
moment. Yeah. Even even if he would like be Ian up she'd be very
into it. For whatever it's worth, every time Michael Briggs,
my disgraced boxing coach, would reference Gabe, he would always
refer to him as gorgeous Gabe. He couldn't help but refer to
him as Gorgeous Gabe on the >> I would call I would call
him Gorgeous >> Isn't that cuz he's like >> he's
a beautiful guy. >> Yeah, he's a He is a Yeah, he's got
>> Isn't that because of what they're setting up? There's
a reason they're calling him Gorgeous Gabe. Idubbbz, are you
unaware? >> Got tattoos. He's large. He's tan. >> I
don't call him that. My wife doesn't call him that. If if you
have some
tension or fantasies, whatever the it is, you need to keep that
[__] to yourself and not project it onto other people.
I wish the best to Gabe. Michael Briggs on the other hand, absolute
creep
Yeah, don't you shouldn't try to be nice. Shouldn't try to be
fair. What you have to do here is you need to start explaining
that like the reason this guy was focused on Ana being focused
on this other boxer is because this guy wanted to him too. Okay?
Right? Like this guy was watching Ana flirting with this guy.
So you need to do some like this. Come >> I know a lot
of this is very grotesque and obsess.
I would prefer if people didn't talk about me and my wife or
other people in this way. I briefly want to talk about the concept
of being a lull cow because dude, dude, why
why would you briefly want to talk about that concept? >> These
losers,
they love the concept of like labeling someone a lull cow and
then like bullying them and watching their life spiral out of
control. They won't, you know, say as much. They'll just be like,
"Yeah, we just do it for laughs. The whole thing's entertainment.
It's just a, you know, just innocent guys just having a laugh.
Thankfully, Anise and I are in a much safer and privileged position
than many other people who are the targets of guys like this
who want to bully them into submission. So, now I want to look
at two different clips from these guys. There is the fat one
and his cohort who are listening to Ana describe like essentially
having a hard time online
seeing people mock and make fun of her dad with Alzheimer's.
People don't do that, do they? There's no way. Did PPP and Warski
really make fun of her dad having Alzheimer's? That's up. Oh,
wait.
Oh, I get it now. No, I remember the >> You were laughing
at my dad for getting sick on some of these forums. Like,
What did you think would because you shared it online?
>> I mean, like that's what people are going to do because
they want to get a reaction out of you. >> I don't think
they probably even really believe the stuff that they're saying,
but they know. >> It's almost like, wait, is PPP
is PPP actually going to just explain the entire process to Idubbbz
directly and Anista directly instead of making fun of them? PPB
is going to sit here and explain, "Oh, probably most people talking
like this. Don't even actually believe the thing they're saying,
okay? They're just going to make fun of you. They just want a
reaction. The only thing you can give them to make them win is
your reaction." Oh, he's just going to lay it all out in simple
English for you. The exact reason why making this video is stupid.
And then you're going to clip it. You're going to include it
in your video like you're cooking
I mean,
what did you think would because you shared it online?
>> I mean, like that's what people are going to do because
they want to get a reaction out of you. >> I don't think
they probably even really believe the stuff that they're saying,
but they know because it's extreme and like edgy that it will
cause you mentally spiral like this. So, that's why they do it.
And you're telling them that it affects you. So, guess what?
They're going to keep doing it. This is how the internet works.
I it it shouldn't be, but that's how it is. >> The whole
time he's not saying that he is a per
random random cutout stills of PPP just look very interesting.
He looks like a video game character like every time.
Curious. You buying the Go look at my Twitter, Koser. I I have
like 200 bucks riding. By the way, Nick's making a lot of money,
okay? A lot of super chats right now, Koser. Okay. He needs to
pay my bets. I bet a bunch of people that he is not a groper.
Okay, that guy is a groper.
Nick better make me whole on that one. Okay, he better pay me
back cuz I'm out here. I don't believe I think it's insane to
call him a groper, but we'll see. We'll see what happens. >> Perpetrator
of bullying her. What he's saying is that other people are doing
that, but he is doing it actively. In this video, he is bullying
Ana. And in other videos, he's literally bullied and made fun
of her dad who has Alzheimer's with a latestage dementia patient.
Dude, he just looks like a video game character every time. Every
single time I see PPP, he looks like an actual video game character
>> who is a extremist Muslim and he sees his daughter covered
in tattoos,
married to Idubbbz the and he just freaks the out. Idubbbz is
having to take him on walks through the neighborhood, talk to
this demented guy. So, this is something that he's very familiar
with. But for some reason, in this moment, he refuses to take
any ownership of the fact that he is part of the problem. >> Like
that's what people are going to do. >> No, he is he is
literally How does I know? How did nobody sit him down and explain
PPP isn't saying he's not part of the problem. He's explaining
his thought process to you. He's explaining exactly what he is
doing to you directly.
He is actually telling you directly, hey, just so you know, this
is what I'm doing. He says people, cuz he doesn't want to be
gay and like actually be like, I'm trying to give you a little
hand here and explain to you how to stop having this happen.
He doesn't want to do that, right? He doesn't want to go, hey,
I'm going to explain I I used to do this for people, right? Hey,
I'm going to explain to you how how to make this work cuz I don't
want you to keep going through this, okay? because they want
to >> uh Lightning, how much money you got? I'll put I'll
put another 50 on this with you. >> You have 50 bucks.
50 bucks says he's not a groper. 50 bucks. All right, perfect.
Let's go. Let's go. >> Get a reaction out of you. So that's
why they do it. And you're telling them that it affects you.
>> He doesn't want to admit it. And you It makes you It
makes you wonder what odds are one to one. >> And we get
a little window into that at the end of the clip. This is how
the internet works, >> dude. Dude, you can just get free
money like that, dude. So many people
So many people are like totally convinced this guy's a griper
from like random posts. Like I don't know how you convince yourself
of this. Like the group that's famous for watching like edits
like
like are the people who are like, "Hey cat, hey fascist catch."
Yeah, for sure. For sure. >> It it shouldn't be, but that's
how it >> He says in this moment it shouldn't be. Why the
do you think he says it shouldn't be? Could that be because it's
wrong and it's a mean
thing to do to
>> No, he's saying but like dude that's like saying um
you know capitalism is the best way to you know move humanity
forward cuz people need the profit incentive to actually be productive.
Shouldn't be the case but it is. It's like the exact same thing
right? It's like yeah guess what human nature kind of human nature
do be like this though acknowledge that someone is suffering
and deciding that you are going to attack them online continuously
for the thing that they are you know either insecure or struggling
with. It's plain as day that he's part of the problem but he
refuses like a coward does to take any responsibility for him
being part of the problem.
Oh, dude. I had no idea how disconnected from reality this is.
Oh, this is rough, man. This is totally disconnected by from
reality.
He He has no idea what he's talking about. Dude has to have CTE
like or something. Dude, Zidub's new to the internet. I have
no idea. He's like he's engaging
he's engaging with this guy like oh like this guy he's engaging
with PPP. He's not a new creator. No, no, no, no. He's not a
new creator. is very old creator obviously
he just he's actually engaged with PPP like PPP is trying to
trying to get out of people calling him a bad person. I don't
think a lot of these commentary channels want to be held to a
higher standard. I think they want to comment on the strategy
of things and they don't want to reveal too much of their own
morals or principles. This next guy is the perfect example of
what I'm describing.
That's true if you were talking about a commentary channel. Kino
Casino is about like no principles. There are no principles there.
It's just like we're going to make fun of you. We're going to
make the most entertaining show we can. Kino Casino, by the way,
uh those guys are very funny. Love watching that program when
I got some time to watch some stuff. Okay, I watch it, you know,
I'll watch it for clips for but if I want factual information,
okay,
these guys talked about like, dude, I watched these guys cover
some of Rakita's trial and it was so insane the lengths they
went to in some of the places because they're just trying to
be funny, right? They're just going to take it to a crazy place
and try to be as funny as they can. And that's just that should
be apparent to anybody who's a little bit informed and watches.
Like they're talking about Rakita's kids being like Scarface
and like dipping their heads fully into big big piles of coke.
And he is being very critical of me talking to a and by the way
that wasn't even a therapy session. I just happened to cry in
that moment and I was like this might be able to communicate
authenticity so I'll include it. And then Ian goes on a podcast
with a and gets extremely real with him, which is a profoundly
stupid idea,
>> like eating with your mouth full on >> Okay, hold
on. Hold on. I could see this guy being somebody Ethan could
or sorry, Ian could criticize, right? Maybe this is a commentary
channel where this guy tries to be like some of somewhat of a
good person and cover things fairly and so you could do some
sort of criticism back at this guy. camera. He of all people
should know better than to go on a therapist's podcast and vent
about his very real problems on a public forum like that because
people will use that information against him >> like this.
The same person live streamed his own therapy session where he
actually cried. If you're going to be a
>> oh Jesus Christ, turkey sighting, >> take it the
full way. Take responsibility for having the opinion that crying
online is pathetic and weak. Don't say I am the enlightened centrist
and other people are going to make fun of you for that >> because
people will use that information against him. >> People
will use the information against me. Who's people? I'm pretty
sure you're people. You're the one who's playing this clip. You're
the one who's making this video called the the most toxic wife.
I don't know why these making this video called the the >> There's
no way that's your reason. You're going out.
Come on, dude. >> The most toxic wife. I don't know why
these
don't accept the the full troll mask. They're acting as if being
sincere is impossible to do online. It's not impossible. It's
difficult in the situation that Ana and I are in, but we're making
that choice intent. Wait, you can totally be sincere. You can
cry,
dude. Like Dean Withers cried. I would say don't cry when you're
in politics or whatever, but you can cry. You can be sincere,
but you're deciding that you you should understand that people
will make fun of you. I didn't even mock Dean super hard for
that. Like, I laughed a little bit, but it was just like it was
funny to watch a guy cry. Sorry. Toxic masculinity and all that.
Okay.
Um, but you have to understand there's going to be a bunch of
people who will mock you for that and you can't engage with them.
Seriously, right? You can't do that unless there's somebody who
like would never unless there's somebody like you who's trying
to set down a different set of morals, like a different set of
ethics for operating online. You engage with people who have
a similar set of ethics to you. If you just engage with the most
like bankrupted people, right? You just you have no way of winning.
You can't engage with like totally morally bankrupt people and
try to have ethics and morals of your own and and win. just doesn't
work >> so you making this bold claim that we are like
unaware
what happens when Ana talks about her dad who has Alzheimer's
or me crying like we're very aware that that is going to be viewed
as gay and be made fun of by people like you.
>> Okay,
but then you're taking it seriously.
And now I'm going to react to a couple of these random creators
who have made videos or statements about Ana and I just to give
you a taste of what an average is. And additionally, like in
making some of those videos, >> guys, I'm just going to
cover me getting repeatedly, okay, on the internet by like the
the meanest and funniest people on the internet. I'm just going
to go make a a clip compilation of me being, okay? just attracts
a certain type of person where they're like, I'm going to list
off a bunch of people I consider lull cows or people who are
mentally like disabled and I'm going to tell you to make [__]
uh documentaries about them. And then in that case, like I'm
noting doing that. You're seeing that happen right now with uh
World of T-shirts. There's a lot of people who think they're
like doing it responsibly or respectfully and it's just hell.
It's just like what the is any of this [__] >> bro?
What is going on? Ana legitimately convinced him his entire >> Wait,
what is that clip about? Why is that clip included for no reason?
That's not someone else. That's just him talking.
Did he forget what that Did he just [__] up the editing?
He just He just included this clip of him making a point that
is fine. It's a fine point to make, but that's not other creators
mocking him. And Ana, >> give this [__] >> bro.
What is going on? Ana legitimately convinced him his entire being
as a person is bad. Did I once say my entire being is bad? You're
allowed to be critical of yourself and the content you're making.
You would benefit from being a little critical of the content
you're making. Like, what the is this? Like, actually comment
on on what I was talking about. Do you agree or disagree with
a statement that you should be making videos and documentaries
about people who are mentally disabled because you are encouraged
by your fan base to do so? Do you agree with that? Maybe engage
with the the prompt and fellas and even felletes. All right?
Never just listen up. All right? Never let your >> fellas
and actually change you this much. Never let them convince you
that you are so bad as a person like everything you do, everything
you the way you act, everything you believe is bad. And you must
agree to every like their way of life, everything they do. Obvious.
Why do you think that she thinks everything I do is bad?
I'm the like man these people like also it kind of depends on
what kind of person you are know like I'm sorry but if if like
if Ava Braun was able to convince that everything he was doing
was bad I'm going to just call it a W right you might actually
be doing really bad things now with Idubbbz I don't think he
was doing really bad things and realistically most of the ways
he denounced his his old behavior it's like in the tone and the
way he denounced it right you'd be against saying a hard R. You
You might think, "Oh, that's actually just lowbrow." But if he
just come out and said, "That's lowbrow. I don't really think
it was like that funny and I don't like that kind of humor anymore."
That's fine. But you don't have to. It was the self It was the
self flagagillation that made everybody go, "Oh, you're gross."
Right? Like, "Oh, that's just disgusting." And I feel so bad
about making that content. And it was like the worst period.
I was just such a piece of [__] It's like, dude,
who cares? It cares, man. Like, yeah, you could just say it's
like lowbrow. You don't want to do it anymore. It it was kind
of like it might have even been bad, but you know, you don't
have to make other people feel bad for having enjoyed your content,
especially like your old audience. People have drank the Kool-Aid
to a disgusting degree. Obviously, if there's legitimate criticism
taken into account or whatever, but this is legitimately tragic.
He cannot be proud of a single thing he's ever done in his entire
life. He just feels guilty about all of it because of Ana. >> Dude,
I'm proud of plenty of things. I'm not just going to go on stream
and declare it. Like, what do you like? It's so boring.
Like, I don't want to talk about how proud I am of making the
airsoft fatty documentary. Like, do you guys really need me to
bloate about how I really enjoyed
uh following the the narrative structure of a fatty battling
with his friends in Battle Creek? >> It was my opinion.
Now, I I don't know the content, okay?
I don't know the content, but if a ton of people love those videos
and a ton of people have like really positive thoughts about
that those videos, I would say you probably tapped into something
there that might not be negative. You tapped into something human
that that people liked about those videos. You should be able
to find some part of those videos that you're proud of. If those
videos got millions of views, there has to be something there
that you could be proud of. There has to be. And the idea that
you just discount all of the old things you did as bad. That's
that's I think what gets to people. They just get very frustrated.
>> Opinion is some of your content in the past was actually
good before. It was actually logical. You made some good points.
You don't need to feel so bad about every single thing. You know,
maybe you you did some bad. You said some slurs. That was bad.
Whatever. Dude, I I know. I I just This is so frustrating. Okay.
Well, if you know, then does he know the impression he gave with
like his comeback videos and stuff with like the videos where
he's like denouncing his old content? Does he know the impression
he gave? Cuz he gave the wrong impression. Maybe if you if you
just know that that you don't have to hate every part of what
you did, then why did you make it look that way? Why did you
make it sound that way? Rating. I just want to say like a lot
of the things that I'm going to talk about are going to be upsetting
or they're going to be a downer to you because that that's interesting.
Like I I don't know if it's because I have a higher threshold.
It kind of feels like I do, right? A lot of the things that these
commentators are commenting on is they're saying like, "Oh my
gosh, that would crush me basically if my wife described me in
that way or said that about me." And it's like, okay, you it
would it would hurt you. You're feeling bad through me. You think
that I'm feeling those same feelings that you're feeling. I'm
not >> of like good [__] to your content as
well. You're legitimately, you know, fighting against like evil
people and [__] like that >> because I'm sensing
this guy as being his own version of sincere because I honestly
think a I don't know how old this guy is, but I'm going to say
a teenager, a teenage commentary YouTuber. I'm going to say that
their version of sincere is going to look very different than
mine. I'll take what I can get right now from this guy. When
I'm giving my actual authentic take about something, you don't
need to put the blame on my wife. You don't need to say that
she's controlling me. This is very off base. People who are in
I'm going to say you kind of set her up for that, right? When
you like totally 180 on your previous takes and like everything
just like everything you've done up to this point, you kind of
set her up to be received that way by your fans.
If you go and you like stop making content for a long period
of time, you're getting married, you're like living your life,
you come back, you go, "Actually, everything about the way I
was doing that sucked." Yeah. Unfortunately, you sort of set
her the up, bro. Relationships, they communicate, they talk.
This is just the reality of getting in a relationship and becoming
more inshed like it. It happens. You know, if we eventually have
a kid together, like it's very important that we're on the same
page and that we communicate. I know it might feel like you have
some outsider insight,
but it is it is just very wrong. I feel very free to uh speak
my truth.
Yeah, I agree. Bri.
Oh, dude. >> Do you want to know? >> I'm going to
hear a techone comment here. It's going to be totally stupid.
God, why does techone have to exist? Why this makes me so mad
because there was a point in time back in Only Fang season one
where I was like, "Dude, Idubbbz is the man. Such a chill guy.
So down to earth. Loved meeting him in real life. Loved playing
games with him. This guy was the man." >> I think TechTone
is remembering this in a kind of a weird way. It seems like he's
very nostalgic and and happy about it. He's being very over the
top of how epic I was. But by this time, everyone had like decided
that Ana controls my life and that I'm a beta male soy boy. So,
it's it actually is very funny that he's coming out now saying
like, "Man, he was the man just 2 years ago." It's like, "Dude,
the cat was out of the bag two years ago." Also, it's weird because
I didn't play games with him other than we were in the same guild.
I don't know. I think he's just trying to add on to this narrative
that the internet likes of, man, he used to be so awesome, he
was so cool, and then he got corrupted by that. >> He was
one of my favorite content creators of all time. And to see that
this is >> I I feel like there's no way Teone even watched
him. Teone didn't even watch this guy. Tech was like a gotcha
guy. Techone doesn't even want he like dude this guy's like the
biggest um oh what would you call him like chameleon? Dude Tone's
like the biggest chameleon. I guarantee you didn't even watch
this. >> What he became? I mean this guy inspired
me to do content. Like my breakdowns on people's entire character
was inspired by Idubbbz and it's so lame. Like to see what one
woman's and Hassan can do to a is insane to me. And if he just
would have remained true to himself, he wouldn't have ended up
this husk of a man he is today and probably would have way more
viewers and wouldn't having to be making >> I'll be real.
I'll be real. Okay. I don't think crying on camera is a good
idea. But I think I think Idubbbz's actually crying on camera
and not trying to spin it, not trying to narrativeize it is like
a thousand times more sincere and more real than you crying about
Hassan calling your dad a. That was some of the most disgusting
I've ever seen on the internet. And I think Idubbbz is like a
thousand times better person than you. Like Tech's actually this
guy's like different from like there are people who are harm.
This guy's just like a parasite that is frustrating to know is
out here. Like I I'm having a hard time just like staying in
the >> cont for money. It's just this is such cope, man.
Like hearing techone say it, it's just like it's reminding me
how many times I've heard this script. These people cannot fathom
that the based epic n-word guy has changed his mind over time.
It's got to be a woman's or Hassan. I I think if they accept
that I came to that decision on my own, they have to reckon with
some demons of their own. Like they So he could totally say he
came to this decision on his own, but he has to he has to talk
about the experiences that got him there. It can't just be like
these opinions didn't just like materialize out of thin air,
right? You need to explain to people how you got to those places
and it needs to make sense. If you can't do that, people will
figure out an explanation that makes sense to them. And the explanation
that makes sense to them is you were you like were a virgin and
your wife [__] you and you just took her, did anything
she said. That's the version everybody else will use. You have
to I think he said it was talking to Ana, was it? Well, he did
say that that like Yeah, he he also added that. Yes. Like if
you don't just just give the reasons that aren't your wife or
give the reasons that are your wife, but then understand that
that's what people are going to say. It's it's hard to accept
the fact that I've taken this journey and it's not one I regret.
It's actually one that I've uh felt better after doing. >> And
Techon is right. This guy is such a disappointment. Like Idubbbz's
calling people incels when the first woman he met literally destroyed
like took over his life and destroyed him. Dude, >> I don't
know if this is your own theory or if it's just like implanted
in your brain from >> Dude, I will say though, it's up
of Ana not to keep the long hair. Okay, that was up. And to get
those tattoos. Oh, did I just skip backwards? God damn it. Hold
on. We were right
right here.
How far? We weren't that far. I can't I'm not even getting to
the Anisha >> because I people who are in relationships,
they communicate, they talk over >> one woman's and we're
way past >> and certainly not the first woman I've had
with >> and it's not one I regret. and Hassan >> and
like hearing techone say it it's just like it's remind I don't
know videos but Ana is not the first person or not the first
woman I've met. I've met plenty of other women. Uh she's certainly
not the first woman I've dated and certainly not the first woman
I've had sex with.
But I will admit that she is the first woman I married. I could
have sworn that Ana did say explicitly.
Yeah. I I could have sworn she did say that. Not the first I
don't know if you know this, Teone, but Ana was not the first
woman I met. She was not okay. She was not the first person.
She was not the first woman I ever met. Teone,
>> Also, there are a lot of grown men out there who were
outraged to find out that I changed my last name from Washburn
to Jamba when I married Ana who took his >> Oh, that also
that man that's just insane. Wife's last name. Taking Ana's last
name. Taking your wife's last name. >> He's taken her last
name. >> His last name. >> The last name. The story.
Okay. Oh, yeah. There's so many. I forgot. I think some of these
people think I'm trying to push a woke agenda or some [__]
but I don't give a what anyone does with their own last names.
This is what I chose to do because I like her last name better.
>> I Dude, okay. I feel like I don't know that is that
just bad branding? Would you put it down to like just bad branding?
It's weird, but why is it worse than her taking your name? Um,
because there's literally a societal convention that 99% of people
stick to and breaking that convention implies something and you're
stupid to think that breaking away from a societal convention
that 99% of people like stick to is not a meaningful thing.
the societal convention. No,
you could break a couple societal conventions, but the problem
is is if you if you are going to be if you're going to be the
guy who says all of his previous content is bad because of conversations
with your wife, then if you're also going to take your wife's
last name, you have to understand how you're giving people multiple
things to compound on top of each other to make conclusions about
yours and your wife's relationships. No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's not just a gay detail to focus on. It sucks that people
focus on it, okay? But the problem is you've done so many different
things that it's just another thing to add. It adds it adds it's
like uh you're writing a character. You're making it three-dimensional,
right? You're you're actually giving extra detail to people to
write the the theories about you and your wife that you don't
want written. That's the problem. When my rancid boxing coach
and his wife decided to go on the H3 podcast as like this mutual
exchange of talking about Anisa and I in exchange for $5,000
that was sort of under the premise that I owed them some sort
of bonus money. >> Yeah. I mean like we were also uh promised
a bonus on CC1 and we never got it. But because Michael is so
nice, he didn't want to like make Ian feel uncomfortable and
ask Ian and Nissa about it. And I was always under the assumption
that there was no bonus because even though he told me there
was a bonus, he then disappeared for 6 months and I never saw
him. So I was like, was there a bonus or was there not a bonus?
>> There was never a bonus. I never spoke to these losers
about a bonus. I was paying these people an hourly rate to do
the job that I asked for them to do and they got paid. This loser
with the beard got paid $32,000
for training an influencer to box and she got paid $9,000
to film some of it. They conveniently never talked to either
one of us about it. >> You can >> wait, how long
do they train for? These guys were making good money. Uh >> confronted
about that. You asked them or you didn't want to like
>> two years. There's no way they trained him every like
what are the hours? They conveniently don't have any text messages
or emails or contracts that have anything to do with bonus money
because that conversation didn't happen. They are lying to Ethan
and his crew. Okay, I will say I believe Idubbbz when he makes
this statement because it is just a easily disproven statement,
right? Like he is just throwing it out there. He's just dropping
his his on the table, okay? He's dropping trial. He's He's showing
his Okay. And he's saying, "Look, look. Measure it. Go ahead.
That takes That takes balls." Okay. I'd like to opt out of the
metaphors now. So, I'm just going to go back to speaking normally.
But, um,
okay. I He's like putting it out there. He is giving them something
very easily something very easy and very tangible to push back
against. And they're lying to the >> How is it that we
put on this great event? We raised $1.3 million for charity and
he promised us a bonus. And then right after the event, he's
just kind of pretend like he's too busy to check in with us.
>> Too busy to check in with you. I don't need to check
in with you. I'm not You're not my parents. Like, what the are
you talking about? You weren't promised a bonus. I was doing
my own. Why the would I want to spend my time with you when I'm
when I'm filming a show with Dax Flame? You guys are [__]
losers. >> You confronted about that? you asked them or
you didn't want to like
the >> if it was promised to you, if this imaginary bonus
was promised to you, that should give you a lot of confidence
to at least say bonus, that's potentially a lot of money for
you. You know, in the in this fictional scenario where you were
promised a bonus. Surely it it makes sense to at least in
I really want Okay, I want Idubbbz to get into snarking content.
Okay. I wanted to start snarking on people cuz Ethan trying to
snark on people was so funny. Do you remember how weird he sounded
trying to snark on uh on Ethan and Ana?
Sorry, on Ian and Ana. He sounded so goofy. He sounded so like
weirdly
obsessed with Ana. So, if he just starts if he starts snarking
on people, I I'm guessing we're going to get something very similar
to Ethan where he's like not built for it at all and he's going
to try to do it and he'll just sound weird as it'll be great.
>> Oh,
if it was promised to you, right? Because I'd been consistently
paying you day after day for all the work you were doing. So,
if I never missed a payment for you and your wife and a bonus
was promised at some point, then don't you think it would be
pretty obvious and apparent that you should text me, "Hey, what
about that bonus?" Of course. But there was no bonus cuz you're
[__] lying. Like, [__] these crooked
people. They came on this podcast. They use this bonus thing
as some sort of like weird exchange of like, yeah, we can't go
on the podcast and just talk blatant [__] about our
our clients. So, what we're instead going to do is pretend like
we were stiffed by our clients after they promised us a windfall
of cash. There's so many other truthful things that they could
have focused on on the podcast that would have made me look like
a [__] to a certain, you know, sector of the internet.
One of those things being me crying after a tough sparring session.
Wait, he's making okay money streaming? Is he really verain?
Cuz I thought he wasn't getting anything on uh on Twitch. I thought
he had like 150 viewers on Twitch. >> Like that's truthful.
Did you say he
>> Oh, he we had to have a meeting. >> Yeah, he Oh,
yeah. So, after that, so he was he was crying at the gym. >> It's
okay to cry, but it's not okay for him to cry. Now, to the crew
of the H3 podcast, I have something important to say. I think
you are all pieces of All right, everyone. That is going to do
it for this episode of what Idubbbz complains. If you want to
hear me complaining live in your ears, um, particularly today,
if you're watching this video the day it comes out, go and you're
all I have something important to say. You're all pieces of transmission.
>> Check out my Twitch live stream. I'll put a link in
the description. I am going to be reacting to the H3 podcast
where my uh rat coach and his rat wife are uh being nasty rats
together. Uh so go give it a watch, give it a listen, and um
I'll you know probably for the rest of this month I will be reacting
to and uh I don't know stirring the pot. So thank you for watching
everyone.
>> I mean, maybe he could do something to coach. Okay,
I've got a YouTube video that is the Twitch VOD. Okay, >> we've
got his Twitch VOD where he actually goes through and reacts
to like the coach and their their interview with uh their interview
with H3.
All right, the interview where they suggest that he's a and his
wife got by another boxer that they were training. All right,
we got that. And we also have the Kino Casino response.
Now, I'm not sure which one I want to do first. Okay, I've got
a clip. Uh, we could maybe go to the full the full Kino Casino
VOD is a lot longer than this. Okay, but we've got a little clip.
I'll do the I'll do the Kino preview first, okay? And then we'll
go to this VOD. We'll watch a little bit of it and then we'll
we'll be back and forth. We'll see exactly what we're going to
do. I'll play it by ear. Give me a second though. There's a tweet.
Okay,
a PPP tweet. I think it's a PPP tweet. Give me a second. PPP
and Warski took a picture.
the trolls are feasting. Thanks, Idubbbz. And Ana, you guys hurt
you guys. Love you guys. You really shouldn't have. Is Kino uh
PPP is the fat guy in the video. Warski is the other guy. Together,
they make up the channel Kino Casino. All right. They do a lot
of comedy content.
They're a little bit low brow, but they're they're very funny.
Okay, dude. PPP.
Jesus. They went all out. I don't know what restaurant this is.
Jesus Christ.
and the full thing of soup. Holy. Yeah, dude. The surf and turf.
They hit the surf and turf. Damn. Okay,
so they were pretty psyched. All right. They're pretty psyched
that Idubbbz decided to react. Give me a second. Where's my Where's
Oh god. Did I just skip past this? Oh, no. No. No. Hold on.
>> This is the opening to their next show.
>> It's the party in the casino tonight.
>> You can't
We're getting the Porsche Warski.
We're getting the Varski.
We're going to have BMWs and jet skis and toilets lined [__]
gold.
Break your task. Come on. Yeah.
>> Oh boy.
We're going to have golden briefcases.
Come on. Let's
party going on right here.
A celebration that last throughout the year. >> So bring
your good time
>> and your laughter, too. Oh, we're going to laugh tonight.
Drink this party with your cut to music. Let's go. We We are
out of the sector
and into the >> You know Idubbbz is in the sector. Did
you hear him?
>> In the hills.
>> All of that time
going through the bogs watching. Oh man.
these guys >> My loyalty as a viewer is >> These
guys are like so funny. You have to you have to take them a certain
way. Okay. You take them a certain way, but they're so funny.
26k views after two days. Yeah. They don't have like a YouTube
channel. They stream on kick. They do the stream live. They like
do live streams. This is just a clip channel. They got a bunch
of different clip channels and they just post clips of these
two like doing this stream. But they dude, if you look at their
kick channel, hold on. I don't even know if they're live right
now, but give me a second. Oh, we could look at this again after.
Just give me a sec.
You look at Dude, their their subs are insane, dude. Weekly top
gifters 360 225. I wouldn't be shocked if they have the most
subs of like any stream. Let me open up XQC. See if XQC is better.
Uh XQC is way lower than Kino Casino. Like XQC is way way lower
than Kino Casino for weekly gifts. They made like 20 grand that
night. Nice. Yeah, they this will be really high for them. But
they they get a lot of subs in their stream. They blow the up.
Yeah, they are uh they're good channel, man. They're a good channel.
I appreciate the show. finally rewarded Idubbbz and Anise and
you this guy's our only viewer. He's so loyal to the program.
>> Let's cut him a commercial for his show and broadcasting
7 million people.
All of the greatest hits of the show. He's a
>> He's This is This is the real issue. Okay, this is the
real issue. You could totally go after these guys and like mock
them and [__] but why would you just play all of
their all of their greatest hits talking about you and then go,
"This really makes me mad." Like that's what he did. He didn't
just he didn't just mock them. He didn't just go after them.
He didn't just do like anything that makes sense. He put up their
funniest moments and was like, "This really upsets me when you
do this. This is really mean." Mountain, >> here's the
playlist. Here's where you go, guys, to watch 136
incredible videos felting me and my stupid wife for our tattoos
and and his son and all the rest of it. And it's just so beautiful.
>> It's like I'd like to thank the academy for this felty
that I've received today. >> We're going to pop the This
guy's sitting out here saying I'm bullying
He's bullied.
>> He's bullied.
>> Oh no, not that. Oh, anything but calling me a wife.
>> This guy's in his mid30s talking about getting bullied
by a guy 10 years younger than you have 7 million subscribers,
sir. It's not like you can't clap back, sir. Oh, no. Help us
clap back. Oh,
this is the other thing. Okay, the problem is there's just no
way to go back at these guys. It's Dude, everything comes back
to that same Houthy problem. Okay, Idubbbz is the United States.
These guys are the Houthies. They're sitting there with no technology.
They're just lob They're just lobbing like cookie sugar fueled
rockets at hoping it hits, right? And they hit something and
Idubbbz responds and off of like the clout from getting air struck
by the United States, they just get the fund raise. Okay. They
didn't even have anything that you could get air strike. They
had mud huts. You can't damage them. You can't damage them. It's
hard to ignore them. Okay. It's there. You got nothing. >> He
clapped his own cheeks.
Oh, I'm being bullied and is being bullied. Don't you feel bad?
No. I love
bullying. Remember who used to say that,
>> Idubbbz used to say that. Oh [__] >> He
said that he loves bullying. >> Oh, somebody sent me uh
the
Dude, just their biggest stream. They almost doubled viewership
for that stream on the Idubbbz comeback. Okay. Idubbbz has pea
breath. Was this was the stream before two days before. Okay.
And then they made 911. Okay. They couldn't just leave 911 as
the worst day in America's history. They had to make it the worst
day in Idubbbz's personal history, too. Wasn't Wasn't there enough
baggage for this guy on September 11th and all Americans? Guys,
do you really have to? It's because they're Canadian. Okay, they
got no respect. They got no respect for the tragedy that Adams
went through. They had to make it even worse. All right, this
guy This guy had to watch it happen. Okay, they they crashed
a 747 into the tower that is his relationship.
Oh boy. Oh boy. And he says he lives for bullying
because it's a way to correct the behavior of
without violence
with >> that is an Idubbbz quote >> without actual
harm. We're just shaming you for being a
shaming you for being a traitor and stabbing your friend in the
back. That's all it is. We're just pointing out the truth and
we're laughing at you, Ian. and we're having fun doing it and
you're a miserable seating. But you want to know what the real
truth about all of this is? The biggest fan of the Kino Casino
and the Idubbbz and Ana segments are Idubbbz and Ana themselves.
>> They've watched
>> They've watched every single episode. They admitted
last year that they binge watched the haters in bed. So instead
of actually having in bed, they lay down and they watch us just
rip into them and humiliate them. >> And that's facial
expression stickers. >> Listen, it's so funny to me, bro.
The way they did this where like the edit like taking this show
so seriously. I'm dressed as Colonel Sanders.
Uh he's dressed as Colonel Sanders. Warski is dressed as a chicken
and Idubbbds is like I I'm I'm thinking this the credibility
of this channel is questionable at best guys. I don't know if
we could take these I think these guys have reallyed up their
credibility here. Colonel Sanders over here this guy I don't
think you could trust this guy on everything he says. I don't
know if he's like committed to factual accuracy and he's using
this. It's like look look at this evil bully. If you're getting
bullied by a 400 lb man dressed as Colonel Sanders,
it might be time to log on. But the thing is, he can't even fight
back. He has to fight with one arm tied behind his back like
the geled [__] he is. He's like even ashamed to call
me fat. He's like the fat guy in the his cohort.
>> Okay. So funny. You know, he's like struggling cuz he's
like that's fat phobic and that's toxic and that's bullying.
You're better off to shut your
mouth. But >> that's what we said. That's what we said.
Right. Just stick to people with your same if you don't you can't
fight against people who won't commit to your rules of engagement.
Right. If you want to if you are a boxer, okay, and you want
to box somebody and you go up to a hobo who says he's the only
way he fights is with a shiv in a back alley, like this dirty
shiv that he just rubbed in his own. Yeah, if you go to try to
box that guy, you get stabbed. It's like, dude, what were you
doing? You know, it's not a boxing ring. The are you doing back
here? What are you doing in this alley? That's what But Idubbbz
decided he wanted to go pick a fight in this back alley with
these two hobos and they're sh They're shing him to death. Okay.
And it got somehow even better cuz it's like, oh, you know, I'm
going to have to prep a show. We only have, you know, a half
hour of Idubbbz, you know, torching what was left of his career
and pissing on the >> assour segment. That's it. >> He
then decided to go full
and do an entire stream against the >> which we're going
to take we're going to take a look at boxing coaches. And by
the way, I was telling him to do this from the beginning. And
that's how you know he's desperate. The money's dried up. They've
tried everything and anything else. And finally, they're >> "Well,
I guess we better listen to PPP and try and do something entertaining.
I guess we bet." But it's 3 months too late. Yeah. >> And
it's just everybody is going to question. It's like, >> by
the way, I know Idubbbz will never see this. It's not 3 months
too late. You can totally do this, but you are going to have
to start playing dirty if you want to do this kind of thing.
Okay, don't you can't be like Ethan. Ethan had the same thing.
Okay, Ethan also had the gilded [__] issue where
he could go after Ethan or sorry, Ian and Ana, but he didn't
want to really say that he's going to Nissa behind Ethan's behind
Ian's back their names all the time. He didn't want to say he
was going to Nissa behind Idubbb's back cuz he's married and
obviously it's weird, but he's not willing to just he's not willing
to kill the boy. Okay, you got to kill the boy and let the man
shine through. All right. You know, can I find more fantasy idioms?
You got to make of your heart a stone. Okay. You can't have that
sensitivity there. You can't have that consideration for the
audience's feelings. You if you're going to do this, you got
to go hard or you got to go home. Why did it take you 3 months
to respond to this? Obviously, you didn't resp want to respond
to this cuz it makes you look terrible. and he was still sweeping
parts under the rug about why he he wouldn't go through the child
bride section of it because he knows that if he was to play that
entire section of the child bride story and all that Kate went
through, he would look like such a dirty rotten piece of [__]
But he already does. And that's what he doesn't understand is
that he looks so bad throughout this entire thing. He doesn't
even dispute the facts of it.
>> The lie counter. The lie counter is [__]
because it's just like it's how >> Well, that's just your
interpretation,
>> Yeah. It's all relative. The facts of it, he's admitting
basically this all
>> All right. Hold on. Hold on. They're going to get into
spoiling this video. Okay. We might not be able to go there.
We're going to watch Idubbbz watching his boxing coach and boxing
coach's wife do their little bit about Idubbbz, okay? On the
H3 podcast. We're going to watch Ian's live reaction. All right?
Cuz listen, they're going to start spoiling the stream. So, we
don't want to do that. We want to watch this. He's going to have
the lie counter up. He's going to be counting how many times
they lie. Let's take a Let's take a look. All right. We can go
back. We can watch a little more of the Keto Casino segment after
as well. Coming home. >> Thank you, Adam Vision. You're
you're a real one and Katie as well. Uh actually, yeah, I'm going
to turn that off cuz that's going to disrupt my
See how many Yeah, we just went covered at Alibaba. >> I'm
going to be flowing crazy.
>> And the last thing I need is some rat bastards subscribing
to disrupt my flow >> Okay, hold on. >> Living my
life. It's just cringe. Thank you, Daily Zero. Uh it's just so
cringe. >> Yeah, you set up the counter temporary most
>> and at least teenagers.
>> We have the lie counter set up. I'm going to give you
my water at some point. I'm going to get to my >> Didn't
Ethan make a bunch of jokes about Idubbbz? I just found them
not very funny. Yeah, he started talking about like Idubbbz because
he was joking about Ana. He was making jokes about Idubbbz and
then he was like, "No, I actually just meant that. I I actually
just meant that I I Let's go to Idubbbz." Actually, that's what
I meant actually went stream and instantly got banned. Yeah,
Ethan has the exact same problem that Idubbbz does where he wants
to cover. He wants to be like evil and he he can't do it. >> My
lips are going to get so dry.
Oh, thank you for being in here, guys, and showing support because
I I could use it. These people are rats. Here we go. By the way,
okay, I'm not even into it yet. And I'm getting mad already.
I see this loser pop up on the H3 thumbnail and I'm like, "Huh,
that's odd." I I like is Ethan like trying to like I I was not
at all thinking in any world that my coach and his wife would
be on the podcast.
Like that wasn't remotely in my mind. I was like, "Oh, did you
like I don't did he like leave a comment somewhere saying that
he was like upset with me or some [__] like cuz yeah,
the last thing he was saying in my Instagram DMs was like, "Ooh,
like flames emoji or like little celebratory emoji for like the
new content cop." So I'm like, "Okay, like everything's fine
with us." So where were the text messages or the anything?
>> Here we go. >> I have two um terriers. I've got
a >> They're talking about dogs right now. >> Yeah,
we met uh one of them when we were >> So
myself to access a fine. >> Hey guys, how's it going? >> Yeah,
you guys know AB, right? AB was singing your praise. You you
were in his corner, right? Because Is that too fast for you guys?
I watch your [__] on like three times speed.
>> he's going to have this bell last minute. Yeah. >> For
all the sparring sessions, all the meetups with all the YouTubers.
Um even small interviews with like um Eric who also fought on
DC1. >> Not all of them. There's a lot of all of them.
There were a lot of things that we recorded that had nothing
to do with either of these people. Uh I basically paid Kate to
record my sparring sessions. U that was that was it and I didn't
use those sparring sessions. >> Um so I have >> like
I didn't I didn't use the footage cuz I was like oh yeah it'll
be part of a a documentary eventually but the documentary was
[__] We didn't record the things that needed to be
recorded
>> kind of content and Ian promised us that he was going
to put out this documentary that was going to share >> I
promised them. What the is that? I promise them. In what world
would I ever tell someone who I'm paying to record this? I promise
you this is going to come out. I am. I'm I'm definitely going
to upload this video. I didn't even know what I was recording,
>> dude. Somebody just put this in the uh Jesus. Never
mind. I'm not even looking at it. Jesus Christ. Somebody just
put the uh >> No, I didn't think you >> Someone put
the red bar drawing of Ana into Jesus Christ, bro.
Mike, what are you doing? Mike, why would you Mike, what are
you doing? Mike, you're insane. Apparently, this is Anaas according
to Mike. What the, bro? What the gross? Why would you do that?
Why would you do >> Um the journey of how Michael took
this um video game nerd and turned him into a boxer. And so that's
how they sold it to us when they first came to us. And so I was
super psyched. >> No, there was no selling it to you. I
asked if you would be okay training us. I'm doing this. They
This is the thing. We're going to see this time and time again.
The way they interpret all these things is the most like like
wild imaginative thing that pretty much only serves to benefit
them. And it's like, oh, I kind of kind of understand why. Like
we we weren't we didn't have a narrative for the documentary.
There was no there was no we're going to record these sessions
to make Michael look like like a good boxing trainer. Like I
we didn't explain any of this to them. Like yeah, we're we're
going to transform me into a nerd into an epic boxer and he's
the guy who did it. It's so stupid. I think I don't Wait that
what was it going to be about then? You're but you're like literally
learning how to box, aren't you? What was it going to be about?
That sounds like it's just what it's about. Like, do you need
to explain >> is that definitely counts as a lie. I'll
put that in as one, even though there's probably two there. Probably
been five >> That this is going to be a way for me to help
build my husband's brand and also um put the work out there,
but it never came through. And so, when he most recently put
that video out saying that he told a big lie and he was never
going to put out a documentary and all he has is a ton of 4K
videos of him doing stupid or something like that, it was actually
very hurtful to me. >> That's your footage that you >> Oh
my god.
I'm sorry, but if you got paid for that, then just accept that
you got paid for it. And like if he if Idabbs had done that and
been like, "We will the pay you'll get is the exposure you get
once we make the documentary." If that was the agreement, then
he'd be kind of a piece of But why are they complaining when
they got paid? It sounds like she got paid pretty handsomely
to record all this. Dude, this is Oh, I haven't seen this.
I paid for you to record this footage. Like, a lot of people
are paid to essentially be a tripod. You did a good job at having
the 4K footage, but that's what I was paying her for. >> yeah,
that seems fair. >> It's not like it's not insulting for
me to have the creative ability to say this isn't valuable. >> I
don't think there's really a lot. >> It's just the same
footage the whole time. It's not your fault. It's my fault for
paying you to do that. I shouldn't have paid you to do any of
it. I should have said, "No, I don't need this boring footage.
There's nothing happening here." It's just like, it's very boring.
It's not narrative building. It's just a bunch of nonsense footage.
If you're insecure and weird about it, then yeah, I guess it's
insulting. Like, but it was a comment on myself, not on her.
That's crazy. You guys got to understand having like 50 gigs
of like a new person sparring is not that doesn't make a
>> Talking about your footage. >> Three years. Yeah.
Three years. >> It's not an insult on you. I paid you to
record the footage. Jesus. Wow. >> Yeah. Well, yeah. Yeah.
Before before the 61 was filmed. >> Yeah. Did he did Was
he paying you at the time or like how was he compensated? >> Yeah,
he did. So, so I I do want to say that like >> 50 gigs
in in like 4K isn't that basically nothing >> for dynamic
filming. I usually charge $150 an hour for dynamic filming, but
uh because I was under the impression that this is going to charity
me and Michael >> What the is that? Okay, that's a big
lie. Why is she trying to frame herself as like she's doing all
of this uh film work? I never saw real from her. She was like
doing she was doing uh spray tanning. I I paid you whatever you
charged me. Like I literally didn't question any of it. Whatever
bill they sent me, I paid it. It came in my email. I was like,
"Oh, okay. This amount paid."
Why are you trying to rewrite >> You know, would I scale
back on charging them? So, for example, instead of charging him
150 an hour, I would charge >> said that. Nice. Oh, >> charging
them. So, for example, instead of charging him $150 an hour,
I would charge him $100 an hour. >> So nice. Oh, so kind.
Thank you so much. It's too bad you never said that. That would
have been really kind, you know. >> Wait, how much was
she charging an hour? >> You know, would always sell back
charging them. So, for example, instead of charging him 150 an
hour, I would charge him $100 an hour.
Does this person have like filming experience? Do they have like
a film degree or some? Why would they be getting 150 an hour
to film sessions they're probably sitting at anyway? Sounds like
Items just said she was doing spray tans before that. Not sure
if that's a hypothetical. >> So nice. Oh, so kind. Thank
you so much. It's too bad you never said that. That would have
been really kind, you know, like, "Hey, I'm going to charge you
this. Normally I charge $150 an hour. That is such I think he's
gonna say the same thing about what he was charging me, by the
way. >> So nice. Yeah. And by the way, I've heard that
from other professionals now. I'm starting to hear people say
that who like one of the announcers put out a video recently.
Maybe you guys saw it. He was like, >> I feel like I know
exactly what that was for. And it wasn't for uh what do you call
it? Charity, right? I feel like they were like, "Oh, we think
there's a chance for like a really like solid business opportunity
here. You know, we want to be influencers. We want to be like
this this guy wants to be like a boxing coach influencer. We
could get in deep with Idubbbz. We could get in good with Idubbbz.
Yeah, we'll charge you a little less. Yeah, we'll take a little
off the top. Yeah, it's all for charity. We'll we'll help you
guys out, right, Wade? Yeah. He was like, they offered me a salary
or staff for me payment, but I declined it cuz I was like, just
it's for charity. I'm good. But then they took that money that
he generously forfeit a guy who's not rich, by the way, and gave
it to all the creators. It's nuts. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah.
I mean, like we were also uh >> to be clear, I don't I
don't know what he's talking about exactly, but I think he's
referring to fighters payment. The fighters got paid and the
fighters got bonuses. And I think the the talk of bonus might
be the thing that like confuses these two about them thinking
that they were promised a bonus at some >> I have no idea
if you should get into it or not to be honest. We'll see. We'll
>> Maybe they overheard me and Ana talking about fighter
bonuses and their brain said like fighter bonuses that has to
go to the coach. It's like no unless I'm telling you that I'm
giving you a bonus. No, it doesn't have to go to the coach. >> A
bonus on CC1 and we never got it. But because Michael was so
nice, he didn't want to like make Ian feel uncomfortable and
ask Ian and about it. I >> This loser is not nice. He's
a terrible communicator. He did not know how to talk. This this
this was a struggle session with this guy. Every time we try
to talk about some anything about like like oh my god, we're
going to get to it. There's plenty of examples. They go through
it. I >> was pretty upset by it and I thought it wasn't
fair because how is it that we put on this great event, we raised
$1.3 million to charity and he promised us a >> I didn't
promise him a bonus. >> And then right after the event,
he's just kind of telling >> I didn't even talk we didn't
even talk to them about the we didn't use the word bonus anywhere.
>> I'll be real. Yeah. Idubbbz is not doing great. I normally
get really annoyed when people are like, "This content sucks."
But it is it's not hitting me that hard either.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see where we're g go. >> Like,
he's too busy to check in with us, you know? And >> I was
told that he was going to be like super emotional doing this
reaction.
And I don't think this is going anywhere near as bad as I was
led to believe. People have like a bad view of this. I feel like
I feel like this is actually not anywhere near as bad as I thought
it was going to be based on what I'd heard. I'd heard this guy
was like an emotional wreck and he's like totally losing it.
I'd say he's like probably going slow
or he's he's like pausing a lot and and the lie counter is probably
stupid and he's probably going to get nitpicky, but it's like
it's not like he's um like about to cry or something, right?
>> After Okay, let's update this lie counter with a couple
more >> after the event. Like once the event ended, I didn't
see him again for about 5 months. Uh so he was >> I'm such
an for that one, man. I'm such an He didn't see me for months.
What a piece of I am >> working with Dax on some show and
so he never trained. So the only eight times that Ian ever actually
trained was, >> by the way, a lot of this is his insecurity
as a coach. Like he he felt bad and he made it very apparent
that he felt bad when his fighters would lose because it reflected
poorly on him. Like like this is this is it. He's trying to come
up with an excuse and basically say, "Yeah, he didn't train for
6 months and uh that's potentially why he lost." It's not cuz
I'm a bad coach. That can't be the reason. It's like I never
blamed you. I I was happy with you as a coach up until this point.
>> Uh I trained him from July until May and then I didn't
see him again pretty much for several months and then he started
training again to fight Alex pretty much. We started at like
the end of December and then that's when like they had to kind
of get serious with the camp cuz they realized like Alex was
training hard. So really I only had 10 months with him to begin
with and then about four plus months. >> Only 10 months?
That's only 10 months >> with them for the second event
and then I've never seen him again since then. >> Yeah,
you know. Um yes, of course you didn't see me since then. It's
cuz I'm done. I'm done boxing. I'm not I'm not using you as a
coach. Like
I don't know. Should I Should I have handwritten a note and and
sent it to you like, "Hey, it was a good run, but I think we
should part ways." No, I was being nice.
anyway, okay. I'm going to continue on with this a little bit.
It was starting to heat up a little bit. >> I was like,
"All right, we'll we'll we'll drift apart. That's okay by me."
I was talking to AB. I think it was pretty normal that the boxers
at least gave their coaches a tip, especially because you were
there. You weren't and you weren't just working for him. You
were helping everybody out. It seems like you were all you guys
were both like super involved in this event.
>> I mean I paid for them to travel to LA and and to to
Florida. Like their [__] was all paid for the flights,
the hotels. Like if they didn't want to go at any point, they
literally didn't have to go like
at any point in time. It wasn't important. They weren't going
to be fired if if they didn't go. like it was trips to essentially,
you know, meet fighters, try to find coaches, and you know, their
their existence there was like that was something that I wanted.
I was like, it would be nice if you guys came, but they didn't
have to. I just paid them to come.
Crazy. >> One of the Yeah. One of the reasons he was even
able to uh kind of connect with Manny Pacquiao's people who hooked
him up with my Fiardi was like one of our connections, our friend
Eric, ran into a guy in a bar in Vegas, and that was the guy
they were supposed to get a hold of, but he was not reaching
back to him. Uh, so we were able to get them connect.
>> This is annoying. a different connection that I had
made. He's trying to like say that another person at the gym
that I was going to was was like was his connection. It wasn't
his connection. I talked to this guy. I made the phone calls.
I sent the messages. You were just existing in the background.
And now you're like weirdly trying to take credit for it. Cool.
We got to add that to the lie counter as well. >> Connected
with the people that connected them with Mike Leonardi. So, we
were literally there from the I was I was there from the beginning
for everything. >> I mean, that ain't true. What the I
was doing all sorts of [__] calls before I even reached
out to you. But okay, I get it. It doesn't fit the narrative.
>> Um, so that's you guys had a really unique point of
view where you had like a front row seat to everything. It seemed
like you were with them intimately more than probably anyone
else involved in this event. So there's all these interesting
little details that you guys shared with me. For example, one
being >> Rob is unstoppable. Rob is a bunch of dumb takes.
The thing about Rob is like I just don't want to I I can't speak
for like 4 minutes straight without letting without like breathing.
And it's just like it's like who can hold their breath and speak
for the longest with Rob sometimes. Just uh it's just kind of
sometimes. Not all the time, but a lot of the time. A lot of
the time. Okay. That'll just be how it is. And it's quite frustrating.
So, I just don't want to do that. >> That
I think it was you Kate that mentioned that they did he and Ana
did in fact pay for his son and all of his compritates uh to
travel to and stay at Crater Clash 2. >> Yeah. So they
were talking about that long before about how they had to fly
in all these people. Uh they were first of all they rented the
hotel for over 300 creators uh and flew a lot of them in. When
the first year it was much it was much more scaled back. We just
had a >> it is the we did not pay the creators who came
to Creator Clash. We had a hotel for them to stay in because
that was the whole that was the what you describe that as the
uh the marketing strategy which is yes if we get these creators
to come we we can get them to tweet and talk about it and generate
buzz. didn't happen the way we wanted it to, but it wasn't like
this exaggerated story that they're telling of like people, these
creators getting paid. No one was getting paid >> floors
um of like some place like a nice sweet place, but it wasn't
extravagant at all. And then the second year they did that full
hotel for 300 creators. They flew a lot of people in. Uh one
of the people they flew in was Froggy Tonic and they flew in
from France. >> That's insane. >> And yeah, and by
the way, I'm the one paying Froggy Tonic out of my pocket. Like
this was a guy who came in and I was paying him good money. Well,
I mean Froggy's a chill guy. is not he's not a uh a bad part
of the story, but it's it's Ethan Klein's enemy and I guess maybe
Michael breaks his enemy as well. Who who the knows? >> Froggy
had told us that he was there. >> All right, I missed a
couple of uh missed a couple of lies there. >> To salvage
the documentary
had told us that he France >> that's insane. >> And
Froggy had told us that he was there to salvage the documentary
and that was super offensive to us cuz we're like what do you
mean salvage the documentary? Why do they keep getting offended
over the most mundane [__] The documentary isn't
because of you guys. I Oh my god, it [__] boils my
blood. It's like Dunning Krueger. I I'm the one. Okay, I need
uh I need something to up the ante on this. Hold on. Somebody's
giving me a way to up the ante on this.
>> I think that's what's going on here, which is that I
do think that is >> I'm being asked to cover. Okay, it
looks like possibly
Hutch does like a reaction to this. Okay, we got a Hutch. We
got a Hutch reaction. Hutch reacting to this video. You hate
this guy. He's just like the
Oh, how do I put it? He's so farmable, unfortunately.
He's like so farmable all the time.
>> Find, you know, if they if they weren't really empathetic
and then for whatever.
I feel like he's very similar to Idubbbz. He's got like some
similar ideas of how things should go. So, I'd be a little bit
interested cuz on one hand, I know he has to stick to like Ethan
Klein is correct on everything, right? Ethan Klein is always
correct on everything Ethan Klein says. Ethan Klein is the best.
Ethan Klein number one, so he's probably going to hate Idubbbz.
I can make that assumption immediately, but Idubbbz is going
to say a lot of things about like I think you should be able
to be a human and all of this, right? So, I think
I'd be very interested in like I think Idubbbz is going to deliver
a message. Hutch wants to identify with, but Hutch won't be allowed
to. His uh his previous programming will totally prevent him
from from empathizing with Idubbbz or engaging with the arguments.
I believe that's my prediction for how this would >> Give
me a quick second. Let's check it >> The other
There was never a bone is a work in progress. So, you can just
tune that out. Today, I'm going to be >> I think Idubbbz
to me is like >> I think that's a donation. What the
I think Idubbbz to me is I don't want to say interesting because
interesting is such a word. I'm losing my voice.
Um,
Curly, brother, listen. We covered Trump for like 3 hours. So,
if you don't listen, how do I time you out for a week? That's
what I want to do. I want to time you out for a week. You just
started following in late August. Curly, I think we need a week
timeout for you, brother. I don't know how to do it. You're lucky
I don't know how to do it. No, you agree. Wait, hold on. I'm
sorry. Don't do it. Take it back. Oh, god. There he goes. He
said he agreed, though. What does that mean?
uh the stream today like it's the strange muslap. You can you
know go read nam chosky and uh you know watch the news. You can
go outside like no one's forcing you to be here. >> I don't
think it'll be that interesting. You won't see Hutch resisting
or feeling dissonance. It just won't even register as the same
thing at all. I know but it'll be interesting.
>> I think it'll be interesting. >> Bizarre thing.
People are like, "Oh my god, Hassan again." It's like you don't
you don't this is not courtmandated. You don't need to be hanging
out in chat. You can you can go do other stuff. Oh, dude. I love
that Hutch wants to snark on Hassan. Okay, we should encourage
more snarkers like Hutch.
Hutch being Hassan Snark is awesome. Let's go. W
>> What was I saying? I think Idubbbz to me is like a really,
again, interesting as a word. He's a very um >> he's very
um >> I think he's a really good example of
the kind of toxicity
so prominent and prevalent in
Curly with $5. I enjoy the slop. I agree it's drama slop, but
it's fun. Joke didn't land. My bad. Okay, hold on. We got to
Okay, I'm sorry, Curly. I up I think I I I mis mistook you for
somebody else. Somebody else was in chat. I don't I don't know.
I don't know what I missed. I'm sorry. I apologize. I take it
back.
Is that is this I'm just going to go forward to wherever he actually
gets the >> Particular almost like a person. >> Put
the react in the bag. >> Seems like he was draicalized
away from right-wing politics at some point. >> I don't
know when that began,
but then what ended up happening is he found >> Was Idubbbz
ever a right-wing political person? I can't imagine. So you're
not rightwing cuz you say the that's not a that's not a political
position
>> that in many ways uh mirrors the kind of people that
he was uh distancing himself from and the >> Oh in many
ways can I get some of those ways >> movement that he was
distancing himself from like I would say his old content a lot
of that the a lot of the humor was kind of just cruelty. It was
just like being cruel towards people. >> Oh look there
it is. Okay, dude. I don't even have to watch. I can just I don't
even have to watch. I can just paint reality. Okay. And and it
just that's it just forms to my thoughts. Okay.
Hutch is going to be like he he's supposed to absolutely empathize
with its here. And he'll just have to he'll have to keep talking
about how bad Hassan is the whole time. Jesus Christ. Get the
thousand yards. Oh Jesus. What is he seeing right now? This is
like this like Hassan POV when he watched Charlie Kirk in 4K.
When you watch Charlie Kirk get merked. Okay, this actually the
same. Hassan had the same look in his eyes. I don't know what
Hutch is looking at, but I I can see the pain. Okay, I can see
it right now. I don't know what flavor of Hassan is bad we'll
get to when when it happens, but it will be some flavor of Hassan
is bad >> in really kind of >> to justify not liking
this guy. >> Ray, thanks so much for the tier one membership.
Keep fighting the good fight, Hutch. Love you. Cheers. Thank
you so much for that. Appreciate it, buddy. Ace, thank you so
much for the $5 dark money donation. Idubbbz is fascinating in
the sense of how pathetic he is. Pre- or postwoke, Twitter is
what is happening >> in terms of awfulness.
>> Mouse pad is double clicking >> like cruel to
um was he ever cruel to like trans people? Like how edgy was
his >> What? That's such a weird question. >> I mean
it was like similar to Leafy, right? Was he apolitical?
>> No, it was Wait, would you I'm not somebody who followed
old like YouTube, especially commentary YouTube. I don't get
the feeling that Idubbbz and Leafy were similar at all. Like
Leafy was just like actually crass, actually just on people for
like the most shallow things. Thought Idubbbz was actually trying
to find like some deeper criticisms and build patterns and like
going and like doing deeper critiques of people. >> Have
you made a fresh Twitter account how bad the default algorithm
is? No, I have no idea. Excuse me. um is in the >> they
weren't really empathetic
>> and then for whatever reason now they're starting to
think about like it's very obvious that at some point he started
to think about the consequences of his platform and he started
to think about how how his his content negatively impacted people
I think that's a good thing I think that's like I think that's
really positive growth and often times that's a very difficult
thing to change to grow in that way because you know you do have
to confront your >> remember that anecdote about how a
trans person came up to Idubbbz and said they weren't sure Idubbbz
approved of it no >> a little bit um that's a really difficult
thing most people are going to find a way either consciously
or unconsciously to avoid confronting the reality that they hurt
people with their actions. You know, most people that's a really
difficult thing. Like I feel like for most people that kind of
accountability is actually kind of rare. So that was like a really
positive thing that I saw from him. Um but then he did the the
the content the content cop and I was like, "Oh, there's limitations
to this empathy." Like you can't say that you've discovered empathy
in your 30s, but then kind of laugh at CPS being called on Ethan's
family. Oh, the Listen guys, it's just performative empathy because
listen, it's just performative empathy because he laughed at
Ethan CPS called on >> like you can't say that you've discovered
empathy in your 30s but then kind of laugh at CPS being called
on Ethan's family.
>> Nobody ever like literally I don't like dude it's like
bad empata and this is the exact plan. And this is the flavor
of Han is bad we're going to get, okay? Is Bad and Panado laughed
about this and made money off of it. Therefore, anybody remotely
on that side of the political spectrum deserves it. Deserves
to be treated as if they laughed at it and and were totally going
hard on that. Denims,
wait, I don't think Denim's ever laughed at CPS getting called
on him either. I think Denim's laughed at the idea that he was
like not cleaning up his dog. I don't think Denim's laughed at
him getting CPS called on him.
Like you guys have to be careful with the things you say, right?
You have to actually say things that are real. Don't just make
things up. Idubbbz did say he laughed. I think what Idubbbz called
it comedic. >> There's a there's a there's an inongruence
there. You know what I mean? Like se selective empathy is just
kind of like it's not necessarily bigotry, but like like selective
empathy is not really it's not really empathy. Um >> selective
empathy is not really empathy. No, I'd say universal empathy
is like incredibly rare. Basically everybody has selective empathy.
Hutch has selective empathy. When the when the doxy was getting
bad, I reached out to Hutch for a conversation. I was just going
to be like, "Hey man, um just so you know, like I'm uh I'm chill.
I am not involved in any of this. If you if anybody tells you
I'm involved in any of this, could you ask them for for like
uh info on it or could you ask them for like proof of that?"
Right? And he would not talk to me. He wouldn't talk to me offline.
He wouldn't talk to me online. How is that not selective empathy?
How is that not him just going, you know what, like this guy,
I don't want to I don't want to be around this guy. Like he does
the same [__] He's the same. Which by the way, I
don't care. It's fine. Right. Like I'll mention it now because
he's he's trying to act like oh guys, selective empathy. That's
like that's that's almost bigotry. That's like No, that's everybody,
bro. Don't act like that's not just the normal way people are.
>> I feel like I want to come up with like a a quippy kind
of phrase like, you know, like a like a bumper sticker. >> No
choice. >> Like what's another word for selective? >> Epically
owned noob. >> What's a word to describe selective empathy?
I mean it can be like racism, bigotry, right? Like if you can
only empathize with people that that are in the same like ethnic
group or religious group, you know? Um is it possible to be a
Yes, that is that is uh that could be some kind of bigotry.
It's how most people are set up in every possible way. The ingroup
is somebody you empathize with. That's every that's like every
I don't even know if that's just every human. That's probably
like every animal every like at least homoded >> a selective
empath whatever. Anyways, but it's very it's very clear that
at some point along the way he started to find a sense of community
and belonging.
>> So, everyone is kind of a bigot. Yeah. Basically,
did the I I don't know if I have mentioned this year the uh what
is it the reflexive pain study or the there's a study that basically
shows um it's like a a hand being shown to you on a screen and
they poke it with a pin or they tickle it with a feather. Okay?
And if that hand is the same race as you, the the empathetic
pain response you have is higher unironically for like everybody.
It's like across the board that is the case right now. Not just
race. If they actually label that hand with religion and you
are the religion of that person, okay, empathetic, empathetic
pain response
bounces upwards massively just by having a label that you identify
with. Okay, you have a bigger. So basically you you see the hand
and it goes to get pin poked by a pin, right? And and because
that pin hits and and they pull back in pain, you have an empathetic
pain response, right? You go, "Oh, you you know you watch somebody
get kicked in the balls, you go, "Ah." If you're a guy, I don't
know what the equivalent for women is, but yeah, you you like
ah right now. You want to know the up thing? Okay, the really
up thing is they took this experiment one step further beyond
just like, oh, religion or race. They took it one step further.
They put they put participants in a room.
They flipped the coin and assigned them to heads or tails. A
group heads or tails based on a coin flip. That group formed
instantly. That group has no pre-existing bias to it. If they
show the hand and they label it heads increased, massively increased
empathetic pain response. The group doesn't even have to actually
mean anything. Belonging to that group, being able to map yourself
onto that group, even if it's superficial. Okay, this is why
you can go to college and have like just immediately be a massive
fan of like your college football team or something with no thoughts
at all, right? That's actually base, not going to lie. It's it's
like how humans form tribes. It's how you form relationships.
It's like a super and like it's how you would not get if you
like found yourself with a different tribe or something. Just
ingroup, outgroup. Yeah, it's ingroup, outgroup, but it's like
um you can form the the in-group out of anything. It doesn't
even matter,
right? as long as you're not like a threat to the other group
and they'll let you be there. You can totally, it doesn't matter
if they're a different race or something, you can totally get
into that group and it's totally fine with like the online lefty
kind of progressive crowd. And I can understand
being drawn to something like that and then feeling like
feeling like um in a world of cruelty, you know, you and all
of your lefty friends, you know, like you're very focused on
like marginalized groups and you know, uh fighting bigotry and
but somewhere along the way there's like it there's some kind
of misfire that happens, you know, because there theoretically
there should have been nothing in Hassan's audience or Hassan
himself, there should have been nothing to prevent them from
empathizing with Ethan And uh even if you even if you um had
strong opinions on Israel and and Palestine and Gaza um there
really should have been nothing to stop people from thinking
like you know what if I was a person living in the United States
and you know I lived in Israel at one point. I have dual citizenship
and I have family there. You know it's like really easy to to
to sit back and really just imagine like how horrifying it would
be to see you know prominent content creators say stuff like
every civilian in Israel is fair game for violent resistance.
like seeing stuff like that. It's not terribly difficult for
me to imagine seeing that and being freaked the out,
you know? I'm what am I? I'm like I'm I'm You can call me white,
you know? You can call me like a raised Catholic, you know? Uh
if you want to break it down like uh I'm like I'm like very British
and Italian. I I don't belong to any kind of like >> I
swear to God I I just put the >> idol, bro. >> To
me, when I think about him, it just feel like the with Ana. I
love Ana. I love everything about her. I've only grown to love
her more with time and a lot of people online don't see it that
way. For me, it's very obvious. I thought more people would be
able to catch on. I am quiet, stoic, not talkative. She is the
opposite of that. She is loud, very talkative, social. People
struggle. What content creator called for all of Israel to be?
Probably. Uh what did Nick not do that? I feel like uh No, Nick
didn't do that. Sorry. Sorry. Not Nick. Um Bosch though. Bosch
for sure. >> Well, to understand that dynamic, I think
especially me being a person who has made a career of talking
online. So yes, Ana will after >> I, you know, I do want
to say that I think a lot of the attacks
on Idubbbz
around his relationship with Ana are like really um extreme and
uh unfair,
you know, like I think I think so many people make massive assumptions
about their dynamic. Now, that being said, you know, like they're
responsible for their own rhetoric and so you know, for example,
like Ethan has talked a lot of about those two, but you know,
it goes both ways. like he's responding to something like there
was a fracture in the in the friendship. Like Idubbbz used to
be like legit friends with Ethan. I think I think they Idubbbz
had even gone over to Eden's house, right? Like I'm pretty sure
they had that kind of friendship where they hung out outside
of you know all of that stuff. And you know if I imagine you
know if I imagine another creator uh you know was making jokes
about like CPS coming to my house and then or or some other government
agency coming to my house and then it actually happened and then
somebody that I was friends with was like openly associating
with that person who was responsible for that harassment. That
would [__] hurt my feelings for sure. I'd be like,
"What the? I thought we were friends. Like, why are you, you
know?" Anyways, oftent times, like in many relationships, be
the more talkative one. We've been together for nearly 10 years,
and all of it has been online for the public to see. And there
are still people accusing her of cheating, accusing me of being
in an abusive relationship. None of this is true, and there is
no evidence for any of this except like, I guess, body language
experts coming on and being like, "Idubbbz is being stoic here,
therefore, he's in hell." >> Okay, hang on. Hang on. Watch
the change there. Watch the change there. I don't know what the
that was. I >> What did What did Hutch just say? Was I
not paying attention? God damn it. >> I think so many people
make massive assumptions about their dynamic. Now, that being
said, you know, like they're responsible for their own rhetoric.
And >> you know, for example, like Ethan has talked a lot
of about those two, but you know, it goes both ways. Like he's
responding to something like there was a fracture in the in the
French. >> Wait, there wasn't Ethan wasn't responding to
something. Ethan was responding to them not defending him. Ethan
was responding
to them being like silent, right? They were not involving themselves
and Ethan was like, "You guys aren't real friends." >> Like
Idubbbz used to be like legit friends with Ethan, I think. I
think they Idubbbz had even gone over to Ethan's house, right?
>> Oh, he's just saying the exact things Ethan said. Yeah.
I Idubbbz went over to his house I think like four or five years
before. Right. When Idubbbz like talks about the timeline,
it's he's like, "Yeah, it was like six years ago I went to his
house. Like I I don't know him that well. like we were we were
friends, but it's like a long time ago. >> Like I'm pretty
sure they had that kind of friendship where they hung out outside
of you know, all of that stuff. And you know, if I imagine, you
know, if I imagine another creator uh, you know, was making jokes
about like CPS coming to my house and then or or some other government
agency coming to my house and then it actually happened and then
somebody that I was friends with was like openly associating
with that person who was responsible for that harassment, that
would hurt my feelings for sure. I'd be like, "What the I thought
we were friends. Like why are you, you know?" Anyways, often
times, like in many relationships, be the more talkative one.
We've been together for nearly 10 years, and all of it has been
online for the public to see. And there are still people accusing
her of cheating, accusing me of being in an abusive relationship.
None of this is true, and there is no evidence for any of this
except like, I guess, body language experts coming on and being
like, Idubbbz is being stoic here, therefore he's in hell. >> Okay,
hang on. Hang on. Watch the change there. Watch the change there.
>> I don't know what the [__] that was. I have
never heard >> like this is crazy. just to validate what
he's saying, you know, to do like a like a podcast stream where
you're analyzing his [__] body language so as to
read into uh like uh like deeper, you know, like read into their
entire relationship dynamic is like a level of obsession. That's
kind of crazy.
>> Look at EM in this moment. Oh my god. >> Like
he looks sad. No, he is disgusted
here. Disgusted with this. >> He looks so uncomfortable.
He's like, should I be here? He looks so uncomfortable. Look
at this guy's body leg, which he doesn't want to be there. >> Look
how miserable he looks, dude. He looks miserable, dude. He looks
like he wants to kill himself in a video. >> I kind of
want to kill myself now. >> In a video game. Jesus Christ.
What the >> Okay, so they're not a fan of the >> They
just let anything fly on YouTube. In a video game, I'm clarifying
for him. >> Resting face. All right. Well, I'm not going
to smile all the time, fellas. And even when I smile, you guys
still like contort it into he's so uncomfortable or he's smiling
through the pain. Oh,
he's smiling on his face, but inside his eyes, you can see his
pain >> for some reason. Well, not for some reason, for
the reason of Wait, I just realized that I need a I need like
an extension. Would there be an extension that would let me zoom
more with my with my mouse? I need that really badly. I need
like to be able to pinch zoom way more with Chrome. Like infinite
pinch zoom all the way in. I need to be able to go right into
Idubbbz's like pupils. I told you that for years. No, you didn't.
and people's view on mentioned that before and just not liking
Ana. They want to push forward a narrative that she's >> you're
on Twitch, you're one to talk. Wait, what? Well, I mean, I guess
I feel I feel like Twitch maybe has um stricter standards than
uh than uh YouTube. Can I sit stoically? Um to be honest with
you guys, like uh I'm, you know, I'm pretty talkative on the
stream, but I'm kind of a little bit more not not shy. I'm not
a shy person anymore. Um I don't really worry about what people
are thinking about me. I don't feel uncomfortable. >> All
the gayest devs I know have a No, I'm not getting I don't need
I need a pinch zoom. I need like my trackpad can zoom, but I
need it. This is the max. This is the maximum amount I can zoom
right now. Okay, I need more zoom.
I need to be able to zoom into this guy's pupils in public situations.
But I for maximum snarking capability. Okay, that's what I'm
thinking about. >> I find a lot of the times that I go
to, you know, like friend events, I can be a bit more reserved.
Like I find it kind of overstimulating. Um and I don't have like
I can't do that for very long. Check out what I put in general.
Okay. Like I'm very very talkative on the stream and I feel like
you guys get like a particular side of me. Um bunch of viewers
also freaks like this guy. Interesting. That is interesting.
Okay. Actively and continually cheating on me. And if you listen
to freaks like this guy I'm about to show it makes sense why
they are obsessed. Ana wants to have sex into having sex with
Ana. I think he wants to bang Ana. Ana was horny and wanted to
have sex with. >> He's really focused on these people.
Who are these people, by the way? Do they have a big audience?
>> Uh, pretty big.
>> What a sad slate of content these guys output. You know,
like imagine at the end of the day, you're thinking about your
cont. Imagine about your imagine, you know, you think about your
contribution to society and instead of a logging Hassan and making
up his opinions, you a log Ana and Idubbbz and make up things
about their relationship. What a disgusting me. When I make up
things about Hassan, when I'm like totally creative writing about
Hassan, that's noble. That's a noble pursuit. That's awesome.
But when these guys do creative writing about Ina and Idubbbz's
relationship, that's disgusting. That's obsessed. That's weird.
That's creepy. That's gross. contribution to society and it's
like you know twohour long conversations about like speculating
about somebody else's life in this way like this is just kind
of pathetic right >> this well Ana herself >> like
who are these people like who are these people kino casino who
the is that like surely you want to talk about like more you
know like you want to do like more with your life is that what
this kino casino kino casino clips 40 >> there nobody They're
like double the size of Hutch's stream.
>> Call them. They're on kick Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
Do they have like a proper like channel? Um, anyways, I don't know.
This is all a bit silly. >> Do it. >> Do you think
that makes her [__] wet, >> buddy?
Cloud. >> That's what I'm saying. What we're describing
here is two grown men. >> Like this is like um like a tier
below Keemstar. You know what I mean? like it's it's like a it's
even more um
sloppy, I guess. >> Who are fantasizing about a stranger
and his wife and what they do in the bedroom or don't do in the
bedroom. That is creepy weirdo [__] And here we have
Idubbbz with the bull. But it's but it's also a reflection of
like what audiences want cuz clearly these two are leaning so
much into the story because maybe I assume they get maybe a little
bit more views when they talk about this stuff. And so, you know,
in a way it's not even simply a reflection of like how toxic
these creator creators are, but it's it's more of a reflection
of like how toxic like people are like viewers. Like obviously
there's a market for people that want to spend hours at a time,
you know, speculating about like whether or not this couple practices
chasing algorithm. These guys don't have a YouTube channel. These
people don't understand like content creation. People don't understand
that people would watch these two talk about like a with 50 viewers,
right?
It's not that's not what's happening. It's not that oh, they're
just chasing algorithm. They're just going after these guys cuz
they get more viewers. I mean, they will get more viewers now
now that Idubbbz has responded to them, right? But it's just
not like they just make it up. They're just too creative.
>> He's like he's if he's doing creative writing of his
own. He's doing his own like uh narrative driving
without realizing it. >> Like obviously there's a market
for people that want to spend hours at a time, you know, speculating
about like whether or not this couple practices
um folks. There's Idubbbz with the bull. is using
terms to describe a picture of me and my dog. And what are we
doing? So many people will tell Ana and I of just like don't
feed into the hate. And it's like, okay, we're going to post
some normal stuff. Ana posts just me with a picture of my dog.
And this is the type of commentary we get about it. Zubs with
the bull. Gorgeous Gabe Plowder in the back room of the salon.
If you're curious about the hairdresser these guys are talking
about, I will point you to my disgraced boxing coach, Michael
Briggs. For some reason, this stupid
loser and his dumb as rocks wife decided to go on the H3 podcast.
They already spilled their guts. They were getting paid like
$5,000 to go go on this podcast. I'm going to be sending you
guys $5,000
for the bonus that you never got. I think they were maybe a >> Wait,
didn't he announce that during the stream, though? >> How
did he show that? I don't really I really don't get it. I don't
know. I don't know why he did any of this. You going homeless?
Look at the editor's note. You going homeless? Wait, is it What
is this? Editor's note. We got an editor's note. An update to
the story. I don't see an editor's editor's
note.
To remove quotes after the verified source who attended high
school at Tyler Robinson said after publication, they could not
accurately remember details of their relationship. Okay. Yeah,
I I made all of my bets before I even read this article. So,
this article had nothing to do with my bets, just so you know.
Straight up logic has to do with my bets. Okay. But we'll see.
Verin, you got me for 50, right? We're going at this for 50.
Yeah, I'm good. >> Was the implication there that that
he paid them to come on? I thought he surprised them by paying
them. >> Afraid that they wouldn't get the money if they
didn't thoroughly trash us. So, them maybe thinking that they
weren't trashing us hard enough. Michael Briggs decided to invoke
the name of one of his presumably friends and say that Ana was
like thirsting after him. She was she definitely had a big crush
on one of the guys that would come in and spar with them cuz
anytime they would spar she would just be super into it and watch
every moment. Yeah. Even Even if he would like beaning up, she'd
be very into it. For whatever it's worth, every time Michael
Briggs, my disgraced boxing coach, would reference Gabe, he would
always refer to him as Gorgeous Gabe. He couldn't help but refer
to him as gorgeous Gabe on the podcast. >> I would call
I would call him gorgeous Gabe. Uh >> he's a beautiful
guy. >> Yeah, he's a he's a Yeah, he's got tattoos. He's
large. He's tan. >> I don't call him that. My wife doesn't
call him that. If if you have some
tension or fantasies, whatever the Uh, Hutch shouldn't shouldn't
say the same thing about Hold on. Hutch should not say the same
thing about the boxing coach. He should say the same thing about
Ethan. Ethan's really disgusting right now. Ethan's like actually
he's trying to use like their former his former employees to
imply that Idubbbz is a He's spending hours finding, paying,
bringing on and having these guys on their the podcast, right?
And saying, "Oh, here's here's a bunch of money. Uh, call this
guy." Dude, he's more obsessed than Kino Casino. Hutch should
be calling this guy out. Hutch should be losing his mind about
how disgusting Ethan is. Ethan is snarking right now. [__]
it is. You need to keep that to yourself and not project it onto
other people. I wish the best to Gabe. Michael Briggs on the
other hand, absolute creep weirdo. Now, I know a lot of this
is very grotesque and obsessive.
>> Is Hutch just like really uncomfortable? He's like,
"Oh god, I I don't want to be >> I would prefer if people
didn't talk about me and my wife or other people in this way."
>> Uh to me, the more um
compelling
uh complaints were about how,
you know, these two ran Creator Clash, which uh by all accounts
seems to have been just like consistently a show. like some of
the >> Oh, so even though listen, even though Ethan spent
a bunch of time talking about Idubbbz being a and paid these
people to come on and tell a story about Idubbbz being a we actually
don't want to we don't want to keep we don't want to keep talking
about that. Actually, guys, did you hear about how bad Creator
Clash was? Did you hear that they like totally that up? Uh-huh.
Okay, cool. >> decisions that they made are baffling
>> um with the way that they they organized all that. Um,
>> I briefly want to talk, >> but he didn't he didn't
even he didn't even touch on those critiques. Just like the one
random aside about like Ana maybe having a crush on some trainer
or >> about the concept of being a lol cow because these
losers, they love the concept of like labeling someone a lull
cow and then like bullying them and watching their life spiral
out of control. They won't, you know, say as much. They'll just
be like, "Yeah, we just do it for laughs. The whole thing's entertainment.
It's just a, you know, just innocent guys just having a laugh.
Thankfully, Anise and I are in a much safer and privileged position
than many other people who are the targets of guys like this
who want to bully them into
I'll be honest, I hate that up, but it was wild to hear the they
spun. I'm just I'm Listen, I don't mind. People want to snark,
let them snark. It's whatever they want to like. If you want
to I prefer to just call it like watching stuff that's funny.
Like, yeah, you're just farming a LCO, right? I I don't think
calling it snarky is necessary, but honestly, if if people want
to try to say that snarking is bad or whatever, or like there
like this LCA farming stuff is bad when people do it all the
time, right? Like it's just it's I don't know. It's it's crazy
to me. Most people who are obsessed with loss have a high chance.
Well, it depends on what kind of LCA it is. Easy. If it's like
if it's like the LC who was like a big creator who had like a
big platform and stuff, I think it's a little different, right?
But if you're if you're invested in like Chris Chan, I do think
that's a little that could be that could be a little much. Okay,
so now I want to look at two different clips from these guys.
There is the fat one and his cohort who are listening to Ana
describe like essentially I sorry I was all of that is to say
I just don't understand why Hutch would be so uneven with his
criticisms, right? It's so he literally said it exactly. It's
disgusting. These people want to spend like hours obsessing over
whether or not this guy's a and then Ethan pays a guy to come
on and talk about how items are and Hutch is just like, "Well,
creator class really sucked, though." Having a hard time online
seeing people mock and make fun of her dad with Alzheimer's.
>> They were laughing at my dad for getting sick on some
of these forums. Like, >> what a $10. Ana is blamed for
Idubbbz's recent behavior because the only logical explanation
for Idubbbz's defending Hassan and company is her and at Hassan's
place she didn't wear her wedding ring. I mean, listen, I don't
think that now his audience is implying something about that,
right? Wait, why would she wear her wedding ring at Hassan's
house? Very interesting. Very >> speculating about
ring wearing. I I don't think it makes a lot of sense. I think
that's a bit getting into into the weeds. Uh I I think it's reasonable
to speculate that she had an influence on on him politically,
but I just don't know enough about them to
come to any kind of like firm conclusion. And I also just I hate
this like stereotype that happens a lot of the times. Like you
know what this reminds me of? This reminds me of uh when Will
when Will Smith slapped the out of Chris Rock. You guys remember
that?
>> Oh dude, he's gonna go he's gonna go to bat. Listen,
anybody criticizes Idubbbz, anybody does starking of Idubbbz,
that's disgusting. If Ethan does Starking of Idubbbz, that's
justified because listen, they sent Skulls to his house, okay?
They There was a sword. They called CPS.
Ethan could do whatever he wants. Ethan could do anything. Everybody
remembers that, obviously. What I found crazy after that happened
was, you know, how quickly the conversation turned into a conversation
about how, you know, uh, Jada Pinket
you know, this succubus woman, she was the real reason why like
he went up and did that. Like, and so she started getting blamed.
>> Wait, but okay, with with Jada Pink and Smith, that's
there's some weird going on between those two. Okay. That's That's
a weird >> And the whole time I'm like, "Dude, he's like
a 60-year-old man. How old is he?" >> Yeah, but he was
never good enough. >> How old is Will Smith? >> He'll
never be Tupac. >> Uh he's 56 years old. You know, he was
sorry. He was what, like 50 53 at the time or whatever. It just
kind of reminds me of that like, you know, he's a he's a grown
man. I'm sure she had an influence on him, but uh this idea that
she's like
controlling him and manipulating him into being like a leftist
I think is a bit it's like a bit extreme.
>> What did you think would you because you shared it online?
>> Yeah. I mean I mean all of that was like very messy
you know her their life and they made it like very public in
a kind of in a way that I I felt was like very bizarre you know
but I like that's one thing to comment on that it's another thing
to
suggest that you know she was the reason why he made this like
really terrible decision like this really stupid decision right
um read the screenshot of what Ian sent Michael before he got
interviewed on H3 I don't know what screenshot you're referring
>> Like that's what people are. >> You have a link.
What are you talking >> Going to do because they want to
get a reaction out of you. >> I don't think they probably
even really believe the stuff that they're saying, but they know
because it's extreme and like edgy that it will cause you mentally
spiral like this. >> Uh the Will Smith thing speaks to
the social conditioning that women are
the temptress and men have no ability to control themselves.
That's what I'm talking about. That's what I'm talking about.
Absol. >> How can anyone watch Hutch? He has no idea what's
going on. I don't really know.
I I find him far more entertain, far more interesting or far
less offensive when he doesn't know what's going on, right? I
find him way less offensive now than when he thinks he knows
what's going on, which is far worse. Okay. When when he's actually
informed, this is far more unbearable than it is right now. social
conditioning that women are
the temptress and men have no ability to control themselves.
That's what I'm talking about. That's what I'm talking about.
Absolving responsibility for the guy for making a bad decision
by blaming it on some like succubus temptress woman. That's like
a that's a um
smudge. I can hear what you're saying, but I reject the notion
that like women are responsible for men's behavior like when
they make bad decisions. Okay. I just reject that I think is
so infantilizing of men. That's my point.
You know, it does smack a bit of like to be honest with you like
trying to find a way to engineer like a narrative that explains
bad decisions made by a man but in a way that like blames the
woman. Um, which isn't to say that the women are always like
perfect angels in relationships or whatever, but it's just it's
taken to such an extreme. So that's why they do it and you're
telling them that it affects you. So guess what? They're going
to keep doing it. This is how the internet works. It it shouldn't
be, but that's how it is. the whole time. He is not saying that
he is a perpetrator of >> um Hutch doing a lot of a lot
of talk about how others may be whipped by their spouses while
I have a clip of Hutch being scolded by his wife oversharing.
Wait, what did I do? I overshare sometimes. What do you want?
It's true. The social network part two. I did see that. Yeah.
Isn't it being Who's it being directed by again? Is Aaron Sorcin
directing it?
Facebook. Get all that he >> bullying her. What he's saying
is that other people are doing that, but he is doing it actively.
In this video, he is bullying Ana. And in >> other videos,
he's literally bullied and made fun of her dad who has Alzheimer's
with a latestage dementia patient who is a extremist Muslim.
And he sees his daughter covered in tattoos,
married to Idubbbz the and he just freaks the out. Idubbbz is
having to take him on walk. >> To be clear, are they mocking
the dad here? They mocking the dementia.
Feel like it's a little the target's a little bit different.
>> Walks through the neighbor. Is he doing like a voice
or is that his regular voice? It feels like he's really
putting some effort into his voice. Neighborhood talk to this
demented guy.
>> Dude, I Somebody get PP that clip. Sorry. Somebody get
PPP that clip. Is he doing a voice? is I feel like people say
this about PvP and he's like, "Yeah, I'm trying to be entertaining."
Have you ever tried to be entertained before, Hutch? Have you
ever tried even once?
Alert. Like he uh I've heard him go off on people about that,
right? But people are like, "Oh, why does he why does he do this?"
He's like, "It's called being entertaining. If I want to put
my audience to sleep, I'd do what you do."
>> This is something that he's very familiar with, but
for some reason in this You know what else it reminds me of?
the Johnny Depp stuff that we've talked about a thousand times.
>> Should we open that can of worms again? >> Mambo.
Johnny. >> Video of Johnny Depp like slamming cabinets
shut and throwing wine bottles in the sink and breaking it and
then people people made it about well, you know, Amber Heard
was the reason why he was like slamming cabinets and breaking
windows,
breaking glass, and like just being violent. Like there were
people were finding a way to blame her for him drinking so much
that he passed. He got blackout drunk during his daughter's birthday
party. Yeah, I'm going there. I'll go there. I'll do it. I'll
talk about it. >> Moment he refuses to take any ownership
of the fact that he is part of the >> Like that's what
people are going to do because they want to get a reality. I
remember people now I'm I remember people at the time when his
substance abuse Johnny Depp which there there's just no doubt
that what we saw about that guy was like that guy was in the
grips of a very serious alcoholism that was advanced alcoholism
and you know that came up during the trial and uh I I remember
a narrative that a bunch of people were going with was um if
she was more gentle and supportive then he would have had a better
chance at sobriety. And I'm like, what the [__] What
the what are you saying right now? That is a crazy thing to say.
Uh, Ace with $10. Uh, Ian was being horribly dishonest about
the couple. That woman is a victim of child marriage. She asked
Idubbbz and Ana to take notice of a law banning child marriage
and they just brushed her off. No, I remember. I watched that
>> Wait, take note. Wait, what are they supposed to do
about that? I'm in a country that outlaws child marriage. Why
are you Why are you trauma dumping on me? what the [__]
am I supposed to do action out of you? So that's why they do
it and you're telling them that it affects you. He doesn't want
to admit it and you it makes you it makes you wonder why. And
we get a little window into that at the end of the clip. This
is how the internet works. I it it shouldn't be, but that's how
it is. He says in this moment it shouldn't be. Why the do you
think he says it shouldn't be? Could that be because it's wrong
and it's a mean evil thing to do to acknowledge that someone
is suffering and deciding that you are going to attack them online
continuously for the thing that they are you know either insecure
or struggling with. It's just a tough thing to transition from
like doing content and you know cruelty being like such a big
part of your brand and then totally rebrand as someone who is
going to like scold other people for being mean. Like that's
diff >> that's coming close to an actual response but it's
not >> diffult enough based on your previous >> like
he's he's almost getting but the cruelty thing he thinks that
items was like leafy items like Leafy >> um that being
said like I do I do respect the fact that he you know changed
his content in that way but then it's also especially
it's especially like Ethan I don't know if Ethan has ever for
example presented himself as like the paragon of empathy and
uh you know uh grace like Ethan I to my understanding is very
openly petty
uh and doesn't really pretend to not be petty. The problem with
with Idubbbz is like he is like now he's positioning himself
as you know an authority on like right and wrong ways to treat
people and
uh you know his previous history of of content his previous library
of content of him being like very very cruel and then also like
the cruelty that I I in my opinion he showed towards like Ethan
it's just a it's just a glaring contradiction. It's like a massive
contradiction. the the >> the cruelty he showed to Ethan
by not responding to Ethan. >> Right. Uh Michael with $10.
Sorcera needs to do the social network prequel. >> Ethan
just like tried to like emotionally blackmail this guy into taking
his side about the printing press.
Johanna's Kepler and the and the defenstration of Prague and
the 30 years war loosely based on Carl Sean's Cosmos
episode Harmony of Worlds. I
don't understand that reference. >> It's plain as day that
he's part of the >> Thank you for the $10. Appreciate him,
>> but he refuses like a coward does to take any responsib
thumbnail. Let me know if it's real. If you want to talk, I'm
hoping it's just some clickbait because I'd be happy to talk
if you had unresolved feelings about me and Ana, I guess, is
what he said here. Was there other >> What an awful what
an awful message. Oh my god, that means so much. What a Hey,
man. It seems like you might be, you know, doing an interview
about me. I would hope not, but you know, let me know. Kind of
[__] weird, but
>> Screen
horrible message to send. >> Is that the one you were talking
about? >> For him being part of the problem. >> What
is that? What is that supposed to mean? What What did that prove?
I don't think a lot of these commentary channels want to be held
to a higher standard. I think they want to comment on the strategy
of things and they don't want to reveal too much of their own
morals or principles. This next guy is the perfect example of
what I'm describing. He is being very critical of me talking
to a And by the way, that wasn't even a therapy session. I just
happened to cry in that moment and I was like, "This might be
able to communicate authenticity, so I'll include >> No,
but that was crazy.
You included that in a content cop where you were going [__]
scorched earth against Ethan and Ela and then you did this like
really disingenuous kind of framing at the end where you were
like I'm going to let's like I'm going to have all the creators
except Hassan by the way but I'm going to have all the creators
say one nice thing about Ethan after like a 29 video or 29minute
video of you just absolutely torture like torturing him. Um,
and like especially Eli, I felt like she got the worst in terms
of the cruelty. Like I feel like the mob that mob was more cruel
towards her than they were to Ethan.
>> Support for Ela Klein is critical right now, guys. >> Um,
and so his tears just came across as, you know, I'm sure he felt
authentic emotion in that moment, but it just rang so insincere
and disingenuous. clude it. And then Ian goes on a podcast with
a and gets extremely real with him, which is a profoundly
stupid idea, like eating with your mouth full on camera. He of
all people should know better than to go on a podcast and vent
about his very real problems on a public forum like that because
people will use that information against him like this. The same
person live streamed his own therapy session where he actually
cried. If you're going to be a hater, take it the full way. take
responsibility for having the opinion that crying online is pathetic
and weak. Don't >> um don't forget his follow up with a
video on concern trolling when he was literally doing that. >> Don't
say >> we watched his follow-up video, but I can't remember
it now. Y >> I am the enlightened centrist and other people
are going to make fun of you for >> I don't know what's
going on, man. I don't know what's going on here. I don't guys,
I don't know what's going on. Thanks for the 10 bucks. I don't
know what's going on. Thanks for the Thanks for the 10. I don't
get it, but thanks for the 10. will use that information against
him.
>> What a stream. >> You love use the information
against me. Who's people? >> I'm pretty sure you're people.
You're the one who's playing this clip. You're the one who's
making this video called the the most toxic wife. I don't know
why these
don't accept the the full troll mask. They're acting as if being
sincere is impossible to do online. It's not impossible. It's
difficult in the situation that Ana and I are in, but >> No,
the problem is is that, you know, I'm sure you were sincere,
but it was just massively hypocritical. >> Making that
choice intentionally. So, you making this bold claim that we
are like unaware
what happens when Ana talks about her dad who has Alzheimer's
or me. >> I mean, that's making fun of Yeah, that's crazy.
>> crying. Like, we're very aware.
>> I just can't explain it. What happened? >> PPP's
got some kind of PPP and Perry have like the same kind of swag
that I just can't describe. Okay.
There's like this this like fat guy swag that happens when you're
like fat and you don't give a All right. They just got some kind
of swag that's like I can't explain it, but it's there. When
Ana talks about her dad who has Alzheimer's or me >> I
mean that's making fun of Yeah, that's crazy. crying like we're
very aware that that is going to be viewed as gay and be made
fun of by people like you. >> I don't know who that creator
is that I now I want to watch the full video. Does anyone know
who that was? Who's that? So hold on. This is around 11. Um
>> this is like Idubbbz did find like the most unfortunate
screenshot of this guy. Like this facial expression is just so
unfortunate. Um actually people are going to make fun of you
for that. >> Who is this creator? Does anybody know? This
guy here. Who is this guy? >> Who's that? Who that? Who
is it? Who's joined? What's up? Why can't I see you? Oh, reactive
Discord is broken, isn't >> Never mind.
>> Okay, good one. Good one. Good one. Good one. I forgot
about reactive Discord. No, that was morale. >> Oh, stop.
Why? Why? Why are you telling me to stop? Is it bad? Is it really
bad? Does anybody know who this person is? Wa lol. What? I don't
know. Quinn reviews. Ren reviews. Is it Ren Reviews or Quinn
Reviews? Okay, I'm going to try Quinn Reviews. Who's this guy?
Quinn Reviews.
Idubbbz. How do you even spell Idubbbz? Three Bs and One Z. Um,
who the is Quinn Reviews, first of all, cuz I'm not I'm not seeing
this person. I want to find this video. That's This is not Quinn
Reviews, is it? Never seen him in my life. Don't watch the full
video, Hutch. It was terrible. He critiques he critiques of Idubbbz
were terrible. Okay, I'll take your word for it. All >> that
is going to be viewed as gay. >> I had to fix this reactive
Discord
>> and be made fun of by people like you.
>> Now, I'm going to react to a couple of these random
creators who have made videos or statements about Anise and I
just to give you a taste of what an average is.
And uh additionally, like in making some of those videos, >> what's
he playing? Wow here. Is that what this is? Michael, thank you
so much for $4. Many analysts such as Ran's Truth Decay report
think social media is kind of Gutenberg 2.0 tech that tears people
apart led to 30 Years War.
Um, you're you're hitting me with some highle analysis here.
I respect it. It's over my head, but I respect it. >> It
was it like it's saying social media is bad. Don't you think
social media is bad? Hutch. Hutch. Social media bad, >> The
worst wife on YouTube. Jesus. at the end of his creator class
she event $25 to basically like just be a little bit less in
pain after going through all this tormented drama. He's gone
from an edge lord to the lord of edit. My girlfriend started
an only fans account and I'm totally fine with dudes off to pictures
of her on the internet.
Okay, but I will be back tomorrow. I think we're we're on to
like new topics tomorrow. Well, probably not. We're still going
to have to figure out some of the Charlie Kirk stuff. Probably
going to be collecting some money from people tomorrow, I would
imagine. Vain
Kger. Who else? Stream TI on. It's not on yet. It's literally
not on yet. What do you mean stream TI? It's not on. I don't
even see TI here. What are you talking about? I'd almost stream
TI. But how do we find out if he's a Grier? We'll see. Chud reviews
LOTR. I don't care about that. But cool. Down until it's on.
No.
Don't shift is so obvious. They know.
Uh, no. It's really obvious that it's not a groper, but I think
so. You But just so you know, Vane, you're arguing that it's
a groper because he would take all of those things that he put
on his bullets and not think any of those things at all. That
he was just only joking on the bullets, right? That the possibly
the only messages he'd ever get out if he gotten away, right,
would just be that. Okay. So, you think he just isn't trying
to do anything sincere? Gotcha. Gotcha. Watch the crazies like
this guy. It's going to be It's going to be goofy. He's a right-winger.
Will you also win? Yeah, I think I win with all of these people
if he's just a right-winger, not a groper. Dude, hold on. I actually
One second before I go though. Dude, Jesse Singal is mocking
a lot of these people, which is good.
Bro, I feel like a Karen with the amount of calls I've made to
employers. Anyway, back at it again today. Catholic patriot public
speaker. This person's just calling a bunch of Dude, it's so
insane. And yet, and yet, hold on. Apparently,
3 weeks ago, sorry, four weeks ago, hate speech is still free
speech. Cry about it. Hate speech is still free speech. Cry about
it. Like, it's so
it's so-faced. It's so disingenuous. It's so gross. Gripers love
Hell Divers. Uh, everybody loves Hell Divers. I had a I had a
VC I had a Discord full of like exclusively progressive people.
They all played Hell Divers when it came out. What are you talking
about? Anyway, okay. All right, guys. will be back tomorrow.
Have a good one. Who's online? Who's online? Who's online? Who's
online? Who's online? Gunnar playing Balders's Gate. Echo's online.
I'll you guys over at IO. See you guys later. Have a good one.
Have a good night. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. W stream. Be back tomorrow.
See you.